hello and welcome to the second day of
nbc oslo i hope everyone had a wonderful
first day and while i can't be with you
all in person today i'm really looking
forward to sharing the next hour with
you
and this will be where we'll look to
solve a question facing many api
developers and that is how do we choose
between graphql grpc and rest
so to get to the answer that question
we're going to do quite a number of
things so we're going to start off by
looking to gain a common understanding
of the api styles that have evolved over
time
we'll then look at software architecture
and look at system properties and the
constraints or decisions that then
defiled of yields those properties
with that base knowledge were then going
to look at a number of conversations
that are happening in the api industry
today and see if we can apply this this
learning of this logic to some of the
statements that lack some nuance or some
constructive elements
and then finally we're going to bring
this all together and look at some
sample scenarios that you may face to
make it more concrete should you choose
to use one of these api technologies
when you either have a personal project
or bring it back to your office
so before we proceed
um a little bit about myself so my name
is rob crowley i am the head of
engineering for a company
called vixx and we build automotive fare
collection systems so similar to the
oyster card in london or we work with
router in oslo as well
before that i was a consultant for a
number of years
including telstra purple or redefine in
australia and the vast amount of my
career has been in
building and designing distributed
systems so apis are a subject that are
very close to my head
i'm also the co-organizer of dd perth
western australia's largest conference
and
last year we had over 800 attendees so
that's really been a massive success
and i'm also available on the socials at
rob d crowley
and this is a talk that i've been giving
various versions of for about a year now
and the genesis was really some of the
challenges that i was not only
personally facing but also my clients
and the companies that i worked with
and while that might sound rather
altruistic there was a slightly selfish
element to it as well and that was
really a reflection that my twitter
timeline was really an absolute tire
fire
and you might ask why is that well when
i first joined twitter it was really
about the same time that i
started to get into apis in a serious
way and rest was the on vogue api start
at the time so i started following many
of the luminaries in the industry such
as mike amensing or eric wilde and i
learned a huge amount from these people
and it was wonderful about three to four
years
and then 2015 came around and facebook
released graphql
and i started following a whole host of
new people
and the problem was
these two groups of people didn't often
agree so
one tweet could then yield 15 or 16
rebuttals or counter arguments
but many of these counter arguments were
very black and white
x is better than y or vibrates this i
found it very difficult to then take
that information or take that statement
and then apply it to the problems that i
was facing
so i was sharing
a small a small example of what i saw
there so back in 2019 on may 25th
actually my birthday i saw this
tweet and i was like it's 2019. you
should learn graphql this is very much
the same time i was playing around quite
a lot with the real time subscriptions
elements of blackberry well i said
absolutely this is something that we
should have available to us so i agree
with him quickly aaron he's one of my
good friends but uh one of the third
advocates at microsoft
it's just fancy o data
and that again is one of the playful
exchange we do see more serious versions
of that going around
and i would like to comment that
actually this weekend aaron will be
building an app with graphql so i think
in the long run i might well have one
but it's not just happening on twitter
so if we look at some of the blog posts
that had been shared as i say sort of
back in 2017
so a couple of years after brackie well
last released
and
there was really a sense there that it
would completely eclipse rest and this
particular article says rest is the new
soap in other words we don't need it
anymore
and i think i found this quite
confronting because i had spent the last
10 years of my career learning breast
apis i learned how to build
affected how to design resources and
workflows is all this learning now
defaults not required and this isn't an
isolated article in there
another one from about the same time
declared rest apis are rest in peace
longing graphql i've gained more
sentiment from the community yes there
was only one way to build apis moving
forward
i personally didn't see that that was
the case i saw many of the clients that
were working with had the same problems
they were facing the same challenges
and it wasn't just these conversations i
had this
sense of deja vu when i read a lot of
these articles and i couldn't help but
feel that
we've actually been here before
so if that's what was happening in 2017
let's wind the clock back a little bit
further
and we'll go back to 2010
and in this case we could see the same
sort of articles in this time declaring
rest being in the ascendancy and soap
again going out of favor
and this one that says soap is
officially
long addressed and the unfortunate truth
is a huge number or percentage of the
apis we deal with today in production
there's still something
while it might be on both to build new
apis using that today if we have other
choices it is definitely not dead and
many of us are still supporting apis and
many different technologies
but what can we really take away from
this
so
if sultan's date and rest is the new
soul
does that mean gratual is the new rest
surely not that couldn't be the case it
wouldn't make any sense
but lo and behold yes it is apparently
graphql is indeed the newest
part one i'm not sure if there was ever
a parrot too but if there is please let
me
know so what can we actually learn from
these exchanges
the first thing that we would have seen
is that they're all very black and white
they all have one view and don't really
take in a lot of possibility for a long
time
so maybe we can dismiss all of this
and simply say
maybe we just don't like xml and we get
off with and we look at different
challenges
but to do that i feel would miss a very
important point and that is that many of
our api consumers the very people we
build apis for
and again something that's close to my
heart is we build apis for other
developers so many developers are
unsatisfied and frustrated with the
api's experiences that they're
experiencing or receiving
and also our api community is very small
we need to work together so we can't
really afford to have
these camps with different ideologies or
different needs
and technologies so what i'm really
hoping from today's talk is that i can
give you a necessary foundation of
understanding that you will be able to
take a balanced approach to choosing the
api's technologies and styles for the
problems at hand
and maybe that sounds a tiny bit
idealistic maybe a tiny bit of a dreamer
so we could imagine that there's no
protocols
it's not hard to do
maybe there's no hypermedia hills to die
on no movement types we don't have to
worry about contracts
wouldn't that be wonderful
unfortunately not
that's not how apis work apis are
required to allow two persons that are
otherwise distributed to communicate
effectively we will never get away from
having to have shared semantics and also
shared syntax so we cannot just
understand what's meant by the message
but also how to decode and encode that
message
so we have to have standards and
protocols so this is a problem that we
need to face into
so let's see a little bit about how
these technologies or styles have
evolved over time
so i'll take us all back to 1991
and we'll start with corban so a
middleware language and at the point in
time this was really seen to be the
future of e-commerce on the web
unfortunately for some it actually fell
out of favor for xml of all things
moving forward to 1993 we had remote
data access so a client server approach
where a client could then query data
from a remote database
so it sounds very like a query syntax
and it was
and we'll see some similarities in that
approach as we see some future api
styles and technologies
so moving forward into 1998 we had a
formal specification of xml arrogancy
and rpc stands for remote procedure call
and it is a
term coined by bruce nelson
and up until this point
rpc was an approach but there wasn't a
specification around it so in 1998 we
had a formal specification between rpc
over xml
in 1999
don box and four others from microsoft
that name don box might be familiar as
the man behind the four tenants of soa
and they released so
so again a heavily rpc based technology
which then used a wisdom as the contract
that would then format the exchange
between the client and the server
in the year 2000 roy fielding released
his seminal dissertation about rest
and this was really about building apis
that didn't work off at all against the
web but really embraced it so how can we
build apis that are sympathetic and
embrace the underlying protocol and this
is mainly for the purposes of the apis
we'll be talking about today http
moving forward to 2005 and in this
period rest really begins to
rise to the ascendancy in the apis that
we're building
and we still have our pc but at this
time we've seen xml give way to to jason
and that's really keeping in sync with
what we saw with the move to rest as
well
moving forward to 2007 we had odata
another technology released by microsoft
under the moniker of a better way to
rest and this really embraced a lot of
the ideas of remote data access where it
provides a rich query syntax for the
clients to
define exactly the data that it needs
from the server so instead of a uniform
interface constraint which defines a
canonical url for each
resource and in which we will then
receive a representation back from the
server
this then provides a huge amount of data
to the client to define exactly what it
wants in the shape
so moving forward from 2007 to
2015 graphql lands on the scene
and again this is really about
empowering clients to
receive only the data that it wants
and avoid some of the perceived
inefficiencies around
rest
and then in 2016 we've got the latest
incarnation of
grpc
and that is again our pc going back all
the ways we saw back in corbin in 1991
and while the approach remain consistent
we've seen the implementation of the
technologies change over time
so that's the technologies themselves
what can we see that has been happening
in parallel within industry
so
in the early 2000s we were really
building apis for specific partners and
they were still type integration so
one-to-one one client going to one
server and it's a discrete integration
this really changed with web 2.0
starting in 2010
when companies like twitter and facebook
start building public apis and these are
apis where one server can support
multiple different clients
but instead of being built
for one specific client it's more of a
conformist api if you aware of eric
evans and the main driven design
where they don't take into account
individual client needs but rather the
final interface which we all conform to
and this has really been the prevalent
style for public apis
for the last decade
and then where are we going to see
happening next so there's quite a lot of
people in the industry saying that the
next wave will likely be autonomous apis
so rich lattices of apis that will then
be composed to achieve higher order
business needs and this will be
underpinned by technologies like
serverless as well which reduces the
footprint and will move to a more
worth-based model
for apis
but this is still some ways off and the
majority of us will still be in the
second wave of generic apis particularly
with building public facing apis or apis
for multiple internal teams within your
organization
so across all of these technologies
while they might appear relatively
different
on the face of it they all share a
surprising number of commonalities
so we have flat file apis so an example
of this might be electronic data
interchange and what might sound
antiquated it is a perfectly valid and
in fact ideal choice if you were doing
large batch operations this is maybe
month end reporting and instead of
sending a paper-based file between two
companies you can do that electronically
to a
defined format
and if that's a batch style apis in
complete antithesis of that is a
streaming api where we're constantly
exchanging data between the clients and
the server and that could be stock
changes or it could be video or data
streaming
we have our pc apis
so most recently brought to the floor
again by grpc
where with an ipc api we are effectively
treating the distributed call what was
as if the network was not there so we're
treating it at a higher order
and we're trying to keep the semantics
of that higher order language as well
with the web api how we call and consume
data is very different so instead of
using classes that abstract away
the network
we actually spin up a http client we
embrace the web we send http
methods to define
again what operations we would want
again to specific urls so we're really
embracing the web with that and that's
the major change or difference between
experience recording and consuming an
rpc or web api
i'll ignore the semantic or design
changes for this particular point in the
tool
and
it might be a challenging message to
hear first thing on the second day of
nbc oslo but
there is no single best apr style
computing is hard building apis is
challenging
what i can say though is there is
absolutely a best api style for your
problem
and that is really the purpose of
today's tool to arm you with the
information required that you can first
define the or
identify the appropriate style and then
the technology for your own problem at
hand
so how what might we go about
being able to inform ourselves about
this decision
and we can take some guidance from roy
fielding
he said that the properties are induced
by the set of constraints within an
architecture
so in other words the design choices
that we make
will then yield certain characteristics
of the solution
and when we think of constraints we
often just think of technology
constraints but there's many types that
we really need to consider to build an
effective product
there's business constraints
so
anything that really affects the
profitability of a company or business
in them so that could be
time
financial budget
and this could be across your customer
your own business or certain product
requirements maybe you're just looking
to have a very perishable window of
opportunity and that's a set say it's
yourself to make time constraints on
what you can do
then there's technical constraints
so embracing all the challenges of
distributed computing so we have the
eighth fallacies so the network is not
reliable latency is not zero so what are
all the things we need to do to support
maybe the security concerns or debate
that we're facing but also how we need
to be able to
evolve the system over time
and the final and probably the most
interesting set of constraints is all
around the operation of that service and
this is really all the socio-technical
or the human constraints around
so how are we going to support or build
this system is there multiple teams
within an organization buildings in
which case then looking at convoy's
normal which states that the systems we
build will be a mirror of the
communication pattern
between our teams
so
these are things that have become very
close to my heart and my current role
where i'm looking to align the operating
model again with the product lines that
we're looking to build
and it's not just about organizing teams
but it's also about the set of knowledge
or expertise within youtube
so for instance rest
to build an effective rest api
requires deep expertise in html
and if you don't have it you will
struggle to be able to get the most out
of that lifestyle
so again really looking at all of the
elements around your teams how they're
organizing the knowledge they have to
drive some of these decisions as well
and so when we take all of those
constraints either business technical or
socio-technical they will then yield the
properties of the system and that would
be the properties of the software system
itself but also the wider ecosystem
everything around the operation
of that product
and when i'm designing a system
i always start with the properties
i define the characteristics that the
system needs to have
or the properties it needs to display
and then i work backwards to say what
constraints or decisions can i make that
will then yield those properties
so it's always a case of defining what
you need and then working back it's
definitely not a case of starting with a
technology and hoping it will fit your
problem
so how might we gain some insight into
being able to do this in practice
and again
boy fielding has some interesting
guidance for us in this case
he says that while there's never an
optimal architecture style for every
application
we can start comparing architectural
styles for the properties induced
and this was really the original premise
for this talk
and i was slightly dismayed to learn
five minutes into my research course is
that someone else has actually done it
so zen academic gave this talk or a very
similar detailed a review of rest and
graphql in the end of 2018
at nordic api's conference and it goes
into quite a lot of detail about the
pros and cons of different api styles
particularly in terms of arrest
which i would say he's he started with
and then started to compare graphql with
um it is a very insightful talk um i'll
include a link to it in the references
that i'll share at the end
but it doesn't cover grpc
so over the course of the of the next
stop we'll we'll weave in some of the
insights that
democrats but then also update where
we've sort of seen over the last 16
months 18 months since he gave that talk
as well
so instead we're going to look at
something that's a little bit more fun
so we're going to look at some of the
conversations that have been happening
in the api industry over the last sort
of year and a year and a bit and then
we're gonna for each of those statements
we're going to
take the next level of detail to it and
then start spilling dispelling some of
those myths and at the same time using
these as the vehicles for comparing
different aspects of the exactly of
these api styles and showing where some
shine and where others don't
so let's tackle the initial ones that i
mentioned at the start of this tool
and that is the the statement that rest
in peace apis
that rest apis are rest in peace apis
and not only graphql
or as another person puts it graphql
will do to rest what jason did to xml
but they're blanket statements and they
don't let us know why or any contexts
are supporting that statement
so let's start by looking at some of the
thinking that underpins these api styles
so
graphql on the read side so where the
client's querying data from the server
looks very like rda so remote data
access it affords a huge amount of power
to the client to request the data and
only the data it needs
however on the right side
it uses our pc and that's for the
mutations so that's again a right or
subscriptions which are an event-based
way of getting real-time data
so we can see actually the draftql
heavily builds on the api styles and
previous approaches
in fact it's also got a fair amount of
http
semantics woven into it as well
so let's compare graphql then to grpc
and grpc is quite different
graphql and rest are both protocol
agnostic whereas grpc is firmly tied to
html2
not http1.x but specifically http 2 to
support multiplexing across a single
connection
and this is really
where grpc is focusing on is about
performance so again being able to have
very performant real-time interactions
across
different distributed components
and if http 2 is the protocol grpc then
uses protobuf or protocol buffers
for both the contract the interface
definition language so in the case of
soap this was wisdom or in the case of a
graphql api that is the graphql schema
and in rest it could be an open api
initiative contract or rammel or apu
movements
so it uses protocol buffers for both the
contract but also as the data exchange
format across the wire so how we encode
and decode data
and the rest is something very different
again so if grpc and
graphql our data over http
rest is really a state machine over http
and when i say state machine what i
really mean is workflow
so it could be a business process which
based on what stage of the process you
were you could have multiple different
actions or paths
and well state machines then are driven
by an aspect of the uniform interface
constraint which is hypermedia
and hypermedia is often one of the
things that we struggle to understand in
a
rest api or how we can build those
affordances into our responses but it's
actually a concept that many of us are
already familiar with
so if we take a look at this
very basic web page
what we can see is there's actually a
number of hyperlinks
we have an image tag
an anchor tag and a form and all of
these controls have well-defined
semantics which then allow any browser
to
consume this page and know what to do
with the data so an image tag when the
browser receives that it will
de-reference the resource that is
mentioned at that url and it will then
display that within the allocated space
when you click on an anchor tag
that link will be de-referenced and you
will be navigated to that particular
page
and with a form
when you submit that form all the data
will then be packaged up in sets the
server
i talk a lot about hypermedia because i
do feel it is absolutely foundational to
the middlewest api
and
while we often see it at the top of the
student maturity model at level three
for me it's either rest or it's not and
that is defined by whether it is a
hypermedia at the end of the day
i don't need this to be a confronting
message i apologize if it is but i
firmly believe that
where we don't embrace hypermedia we end
up with a lot of restish apis that are
difficult to consume but also require a
fair amount of of knowledge to build and
i firmly believe that in many cases
those apis would be able to be built
more effectively or deliver a better
experience maybe using one of those
other styles if again from a
socio-technical infrastructure we don't
have the knowledge to be able to get the
most out of that style
so really don't build restish apis there
are many options that we have available
and many different constraints that will
then be able to yield the best outcome
for our consumers which is really the
goal in any api that we build
and what that means as i mentioned might
be a tiny bit confronting i hope it's
not
because there is no best api style so if
your api is mostly actions
then our pc is actually a brilliant
choice for us but we shouldn't start
saying i want to build a grpc api
so a great example of a public rpc api
would be the slack api for instance
however if an api is mostly thought or
manipulating related data maybe with a
workflow then rest is a fantastic choice
and mr sturgeon the
person who i've quoted here um writes a
blog um api's his own house and he has a
wealth of knowledge to share in the
subject so i would encourage you to
follow him as well
and even one of the authors of graphql
lee byron stated that graphql is not the
optimal choice for all scenarios
it is very much focused on client server
where the clients or multiple clients
have very different data requirements
for server to server communications
there are better choices that's where
grpc
shines or thrift from twitter and even
any rest apis and similar cases as well
so again understand the context in which
you
so wrapping up api styles address
different problem spaces
in some cases restless apis which i feel
have been responsible for a large amount
of backlash against
breast apis would actually be better
built in other styles
not because those other styles are
inherently better
but
some require less of a ramp up time on
behalf of the development team
and grpc is a perfect choice for
synchronous communication between
internal services so where your domain
requires very frequent data updates
and potentially different interactions
rather than the
client server call that you might see
with the rest api but supporting other
scenarios such as
streaming data from the server where one
call from defined can result in multiple
responses from the server or vice versa
where client streaming or in many cases
bi-directional stream
so again different styles and different
technologies support the different areas
of your application
so moving on to another comment that was
coming up quite often in
sort of at the start of last year it's
dived down a little bit but there was
this view that graphql
breaks
caching
and the first question we should really
think about is
what type of caching
because there's many does it just
universally break it
i'm not too sure
so this client side so that might be in
the browser or in the case of graphql in
the denobilized client kit buying cash
there's on the server side also known as
application caching
or intermediary caching proxies such as
smooth varnish or nginx
so let's take a look at this in the http
contents
so in addition to client and server side
you can have intermediaries
which will then be able to hold that
data
between the clients and the server
reducing latency
and while you can do that for http
that's not an option for graphql or
jrpgc
so while you can still handle data other
clients among the server the
intermediate options are
not there
that's really about how they use http
across the wire
so posts for instance which are
typically used by graphql
are not cacheable by by default not by
the individual boxes
and why could that be an issue
because while the speed of light is very
fast about 300 000
per second
it's not infinitely so
so typically if you can get your data
closer to the point they will get it
faster
and where there's a will there's a way
um the graphql community have looked at
options about how to support
intermediary proxies
and they've taken a look to be able to
use the get http method along with
persistent queries
and persistent queries was really
championed by apollo one of the vendors
or
producers in this area particularly in
the node space and that is instead of
the client sending all the data to the
server the entire query
rather that's query is stored on the
server and then just a query id is sent
across and then that query is hydrated
on the server before being executed
and with that we can get back to using a
http
get method
but there's not a standard around here
which is a shame because that was really
what simplified a lot of graphql
development instead of rest which was an
architectural style and a lot of the
implementation was left to the
development hence the large ramp up time
that i spoke about previously
graphql eliminated a lot of that by
providing a concrete specification to
work from
but there is no graphql specification
for operating over http there are a few
unofficial ones but nothing that can
really bind the community
but it's not just about intermediary
proxies there's other there's also other
aspects to consider
authenticated traffic so for instance
any traffic with the authorization
header that might contain a api key or a
bearer token
will not be stored by default by
shared
crashes
and
if this is a case where all of your
data's personalized are tied to a
specific identity this changes your
problems main parts of this
so maybe you wouldn't have used
intermediate proxies at all
so again consider that in your domain
that whether the traffic is announced or
whether it's always served to a specific
client
there's also other aspects such as
the more customizable you make an api in
other words the more power you give to
the client to define the data that it
needs
the less cachable it will become
so in restful you have slash customers
slash five that is very cashable because
there's nothing else you can do with it
the second you make it more flexible you
are reducing the likelihood of the
caches
so wrapping up there's many different
kinds client server and intermediate
network be aware which ones are powerful
in your contents
how do customizable apis benefit less
from intermediate proxies
and if they are valuable then rest is a
brilliant choice and best practices are
still emerging for graphql and grpc
another comment which i found quite
quite amazing was the view that rest
apis are
inefficient and what do we really mean
by inefficient because in many cases
rest was never about short-term
efficiency rather it was about longevity
long-term evolvability and evolution of
a client and a server which and tightly
coupled together
so i think in many cases when we say
inefficient what we actually meant was
performance so that there was
performance issues and typically this
was the result of over-fetching or
undefecting so over-fetching is where we
would retrieve
far more data than we required
potentially wasting expensive data plans
or under-fetching where we had to make
multiple calls to the server to retrieve
the data that we
need
yeah we have techniques for this as well
so we can use sparse field sets to
address
overfetching or compound documents such
as defining json api or hal hyphen media
application language in those media
types to be able to type multiple
responses together or representations in
a single envelope
and this is really where graphql was
first positioned and that was being able
to allow any clients to retrieve exactly
the data into the system
to the server
however there's an implication to this
is that the slowest field now dictates
the overall response time and this has
always been the case with any api but
with graphql giving all that power to
the clients to build up arbitrary depth
queries
we are compounding that effect quite a
bit
so in fact all the data might come back
in a single call but the time the client
needs to wait for all that data to
respond can actually be qualified
and
when i first started getting graphql
apis into production that performance
tuning of queries became a significant
overheads to my teams
and again there's been certain movements
in the industry to try to overcome this
so using deferred queries where parts of
the data will be sent back to the date
to the client initially and then http
patches for subsequent bands but it all
adds complexity and what we really
should be asking ourselves now is should
it be this complicated should it really
be this hurt
and http 2 has really been a big game
changer in this area with http 1.x we
use many hacks to try to overcome some
of the cost of a connection so be that
the
tns handshake or the tcp handshake or
windows gaming needed but we ended up
with
typically very poor
connection reuse and then the high cost
of a handshake quite often in our apis
whereas with http 2 we can have
long-last connections and all of those
communications between the client and
the server happening over a single
multiplex connection removing a lot of
that cost of waste in doing multiple
calls
so in fact looking at compounds
documents and in fact being able to pull
back all that data and graphql in a
single poll
is very much a doubleheaded sword if we
could make separate calls
that
didn't have a performance impact then
that's actually a far better outcome for
us because we still get all of the
caching semantics we would want from the
discrete calls but not the performance
hit of making multiple calls so it's a
win-win
there's other aspects to http 2 as well
such as server push
and
frameworks or open source projects such
as volcano actually embrace server push
to be able to then have the server
proactively push additional
representations to the client even
without the client asking for it
so again being able to if you retrieve
the master automatically push the child
resources to the client because the
chances are they will need it
so that's quite a powerful approach and
while it never really gave traction in
the web space because prefetch
links with general directors were
generally easier to work with it's
showing a lot of problems in the api
space
so performance in http1.x the cost of a
handshake was very high and that's both
at the tcp level but also at the tls
level
and http removes the need for compound
documents by actually reducing or
avoiding the multiple handshakes that
would have been required
and server push creates new
possibilities again there's still
certain issues with efficiency and the
fact that all of those push
representations live within the http 2
connection rather than the other um
caches on the browser so again if that
connection dies so does that
copy
and there's other aspects such as cache
digests that will be able to allow the
clients to say don't push these because
i already have it so it's still an
emerging technology and approach
and grpc heavily uses
for that multiplex connections for the
streaming operations that it supports
but then does http 2 make graphql
irrelevant
so again if graphql was all about
compound documents supposedly do we need
it anymore
and again graphql is not just about
network efficiency and i feel we'll see
as a community this starting become less
and less important as we move forward
but the value of a technology is
actually the sum of its parents so again
as i mentioned before all the other
constraints it's not just about the
technology
it's about the ecosystem and the tool
and graphql offers an incredible
developer experience you can get very
good documentation out of the box using
generation
and it also comes with a wonderful sdk
so we get how actually people consume it
and if you look at an example for this
in v3 of its api github had to support
multiple client libraries or sdks for
many different languages
but the power of a graphql specification
with v4
it didn't have to do that at all because
the community could build graphql client
libraries or sdks that would then
support its api without having to do
that work themselves but also allows
developers to use that tool of choice to
never get excellent developer experience
so when we're choosing a technology
think about all of the facets of the
ecosystem around it
so again the true value of graphql and
many technologies lies in the in the 2
league ecosystem and not just the
immediate technology itself
if you're only concerned
then with
network efficiency then a http2 endpoint
might be a great choice for that
because compound documents are no are no
longer the only option we have for
improving network throughput but this
story is far from finished
another one of my favorites is graphql
supposedly eliminates the need for
versioning
however there was never a need to
version your api it is a strategy for
decoupling a client from a breaking
change in your api it is a strategy for
compatibility that's a requirement and
it's not the only option we have
available either so we have versioning
as being one but we also have graceful
evolution and when vote fielding was
asked how should you version the rest
apr
the simple answer was don't and in fact
this is exactly the same view that the
graphql designers took as well favoring
graceful evolution through the deferred
attribute
or directive and to my mind graceful
evolution should always be your goal but
it does require discipline so for
instance we can't add required inputs we
can't make outputs that were required
but optional
we can't remove them you can't change
the type of a field from a number to a
string and we should always follow the
robustness principle of hostile's law so
be incredibly broad of what you accept
but incredibly specific with what you
said
and this requires
discipline and i guess the key thing
there is don't rely on grace and
evolution alone not over communicate
with your users around these changes so
it's not enough to say
in my mind to put a deprecation or a
sunset header
and then have your api consumers update
automatically
send those are bulletin let them know
what will change engage them let them
know how long the window is that you can
support them particularly important when
you're building apis for internal teams
in your organization but that still adds
a lot to the developer experience of
making your api a joy to use
and it's not just on the server side
so
clients also need to have discipline so
tolerant reader pattern as defined by
martin fowler the enterprise integration
pattern book is again
how clients should respond to
apis so
don't deserialize directly into classes
certain fields appear in a different
order don't worry
if additional fields that you are
interested in appear in the response
again don't break so apply the tolerance
with a pattern and that's what allows
both the client and the server to evolve
independently or more robustly and
graphql makes this an inbuilt feature so
it makes deprecations to the
identification directive
and when i first started using graphql i
thought this would be incredibly
powerful
instead of doing broadcasts to say this
field by change who'd be interested who
should i engage with because i know
every field that every user is
requesting i'd be able to have specific
conversations
what i found though is it doesn't take
long until everybody uses something
so you're always dealing with if you
have to introduce a great change really
going through the same steps you would
have anyway and it's not just about the
contract level there's also certain
inbuilt behaviors in your api about
performance for instance
which
while they're not defined in the
contract there's absolutely other people
relying on it particularly if you've got
multiple apis that you might have
daisy chained together ignoring
multiplicative effective downtime um and
then latency becomes a big issue of
crossbow services if we want to tune the
timeouts
so even if we're doing a refactor as
well of some of the behavior in many
cases understanding that you shouldn't
really fix or change a behavior and many
of those behaviors cannot be defined in
the contract alone so again
communication with your users becomes
incredibly important
so how about we go about being able to
create our solutions that can evolve
gracefully and this is really by
embracing the interface which in our
apis is a contract first design
so in graphql is the schema it's the
protocol buffer or again the open api
ram
etc definition and once we have that
shared understanding around the
interface both the clients on the server
team can work independently using mocked
stubs against that interface
finally you can integrate and the whole
loop repeats again
so if you're not using a contract first
approach particularly when you want to
be able to build things in parallel i
would encourage you to investigate the
approach it is incredibly powerful to be
able to iterate a contract very quickly
rather than having all the code that you
need to change so when you're designing
your api the later you can write the
code or the higher fidelity the better
outcome you're likely to have with less
friction
so versioning it's a technique for
managing breaking changes never a
requirement you can do that for any of
the api styles that
you can support but again prefer
graceful evolution if possible but it
requires both the client and the server
to adopt those robustness patterns
absolutely not a substitute for
communication users and it doesn't
protect your users from depending on
implicit behavior non-functional
requirements
the final one we'll look at is domain
modeling is purely a risk concern um
that's absolutely not the case we have
to embrace software architecture design
and understand their domains
irrespective of the apis that or the
styles that we use
and we should always start with the
user's front of mind and work backwards
so what's the experience we need to
provide and then how might we go about
designing them so again the contract is
a great way to be able to do this
rapidly
and
while both grpc and and rest start with
an outside-in approach graphql changes
this a little bit whereby we build a
graph
and then which depicts all the data that
can be queried and then the client
projects its queries onto a certain
portion
of that overall graph so the side effect
of this is graphql actually allows you
to delay the last responsible moment for
what the optimal queries are until the
users start using your system so you
don't have to iron out exactly what
endpoints they will have because they
can define the shape of their own data
the trade-off with that is
again performance tuning gets pushed to
the right in the process
so api designs
so api design skills absolutely table
stakes irrespective of the style you
have to understand your problem today
both rest and grpc follow an outside
design so starting with the experience
to find your endpoints to find your
operations in the case of grpc and then
work backwards
and graphql delays this moment until
profiling queries so if you have a
domain you don't have a great
understanding of potentially multiple
clients that need very different data
rather than creating bespoke bffs or
different imports for each client
graphql allows you to support that in a
fairly elegant manner albeit just that
in my experience the cost of some of the
the greater operational overhead problem
so with those conversations understood
let's actually look at some sample
scenarios in the final the seven options
that we have together and look where
i would be looking to
apply one of these styles
and the tendons i will always have as i
mentioned before start with the
properties and then work backwards to
the constraints and one of those things
always keeping simplicity in mind so
what's the simplest approach that you
could take to solve this problem rather
than a technology approach trying to fix
the problem
so if you're just building a basic
application web form
maybe just a single client that web page
we use all the data and all we're doing
is posting it to the server
there is no value at all in using
anything more complicated than just a
simple
http post
keep it simple don't don't say but i
might need more functionality in the
future that's fine it's very easy to
change it but keep your landscape as
simple as possible
both you and maybe the person who
supports the code base after you will be
thankful of that in the long run
but graphql does absolutely shine is it
at that composite api level so maybe you
have a suite of apis existing within
your company and maybe the many
different technologies and many
different clients requiring different
data
and maybe there's multiple round trips
to the server and performance is an
issue very much the same challenge that
facebook were facing when we were
creating graphql then graphql does give
you a second chance to build the api you
wish you had built originally but it
only gives you one chance that can then
act as a facade to those downstream
services
but it does not absolve you from really
understanding what those data needs are
but graphql is absolutely agnostic of
the underlying data source it could be
another service it could be a database
it could be files it could be another
web service
but it does provide an incredibly
powerful
common interface into data whether that
data exists on the client on the server
you want to interact with a speed a real
time or a request responsibility type
style so having that single interface
into your data particularly when you
have multiple different types of clients
can be very powerful
something i've been using quite a quite
a bit with my teams as well as is the
sort of bff style
for for mobile apps
so instead of having many d normal many
responses go back to the client and
having to stitch all that data together
really use a bff so
back ends for front-end pattern to
extend the application boundary to the
api as well
and grpc can really shine in this area
because what you can then have is a
single
technology that can support all of the
apis that you have so you can have
incredibly powerful code generation for
protocol files
to find and then cogen in any number of
modern languages
and having a very simple way of then
testing consistently across your entire
landscape
so we've seen that with certain clients
that then simplified their architectures
a lot by being able to choose one style
and really optimize their teams for how
to build and release those apis
and again grpc is great when you have
highly
i would say temporary coupled apis
particularly microservices that all need
to exchange data in a real-time basis
and grpc again is perfect for that
but there's certain scenarios which we
can support so for instance
grpc cannot be used natively in a web
browser we simply do not have access to
the low level frames in the browser
that's required for
http 2.
likewise we can't support grpc hosted on
asp.net app services and we don't have
access to some of the training headers
that we need so even though we can
support hcv2 there's certain aspects of
that protocol that are supported
so again what the industry have done in
this area have come up with a companion
protocol grpc way and that's effectively
a way of doing
grpc over http wood.x
in a compatible way but if we're going
that from a client you typically need a
proxy that will then convert the http
1.x traffic to 2.0 for your internal
services
and
typically that would be envoy is what
i've used before so the
the sidecar technology from istio which
you might be aware from it
but there's also experimental
technologies from microsoft from james
losing king and co which allows you to
run that
on an app service without the need for a
separate proxy
so again as i mentioned there is an
option there but it is experimental for
now rather than a finished product but i
do understand that microsoft listens to
it
so
takeaways
you would have seen that there's many
different api technologies and styles
that have evolved over time
while they appear very different
initially they actually come back to a
number of core styles each which
supports or are aligned to a certain set
of problems
we then saw how you can start looking at
the properties of your system then
working back to the constraints that
would then help deliver those properties
or characteristics
and then with that knowledge we then
started to look at some of the
conversations which are happening in the
community and then being able to look at
those statements and then apply that
constraint and property thinking to
understand what's actually important in
your domain
and then finally we looked at just a few
real world scenarios which hopefully got
you thinking that maybe this is similar
to something that i've been building
myself that will give you some guidance
to be able to understand where you
should start your journey when you leave
or get back to work from agency oslo so
thank you so much for
choosing my talk this morning it's been
an absolute pleasure to be able to share
some of my experiences with you
if you're looking to
um
download any of the slides they are
available at this
url once you download them you will also
gain access to all of the resources that
i used in the creation of this talk as
well such that you'll be able to get
that next level of detail as well so
thank you so much for your time and i
hope you have a wonderful remainder of
abc oslo thank you
hi and uh welcome to my session uh
the five pillars of collaborative
product ownership
so my name's john the drew and i've been
in the software industry now for about
20 years and in that time i have done
many many different things been a
software engineer a team lead a
technical lead architect development
manager tester business analyst project
manager
and
for my uh for my sins even
a product owner
so
at this point this is the fun thing of
trying to translate things to
online talks i'd normally give all of
the product owners in the audience a
little gift
specifically
some stickers because everyone loves
stickers
um only these stickers say
are labeling the product owners with
some of the things that people might
have heard
the product owners
be called
that is that
what we have are things like
the single
ringable neck
the one throat to choke
the
the uh the one person that gets fired
if the project goes wrong
and i i have a lot of issues with
the language that we use
to talk about product owners
um
because
i don't know but i reckon most product
donors
don't really like
having
the uh
the the title
the single
ringable
neck
so
what's interesting about that is that
particular phrase i imagine that's one
that
many of you will be familiar with
and people wonder where these phrases
come from um well that particular phrase
was actually coined by jeff sutherland
in the book that introduced scrum
which i find an interesting
thing when we think about he also
created the product owner role
so
i think there's a an interesting
question when i ask the audience at this
point and they say well what what does
this actually mean what does single
ringable neck mean why might it be
valuable potentially
and what you have is a lot of people
talking about well it's so important to
have a single
point
of accountability
well
i find that an interesting an
interesting challenge really
why is a single point of accountability
really important
well
is it because we think that people won't
step up
if there isn't do we need one person to
be
beating everyone with a common one is
that we don't want the engineers to be
uh to be to be distracted
uh with all of the questions from the
customers
otherwise they wouldn't be able to just
you know get their head down in their
dark little room and focus on the things
they need to do
so we give that job to the product owner
but then there's this other problem
isn't there so the product owner is also
going to be the central focal point of
all the the kind of business knowledge
potentially like an sme
but as engineers
i think most organizations have
recognized that it's a pretty dangerous
thing to have all of your technical
knowledge for a key subsystem in
one person's head
but apparently that's fine
for a product owner
i don't know to me this all seems a
little bit sketchy
so
what makes a great product owner
at this point i'd love
to have a go i don't know who's uh if
people are on the zoom call um but if
there are people on the zoom call what
would be awesome is if if people could
unmute themselves maybe
and shout out just one word to tell me
what they think makes a great product
owner if there's no one there i'll have
to fill in
anyone have any idea any idea
no
no one know what a good product donor is
all right that's fine so
words that normally come up here
um things that we normally hear we will
hear things like
available this is a really good one
what makes something available
well why is availability of a product
owner really important well this is what
happens what tends to happen on teams is
uh you're working away as your team and
then suddenly you get stuck because you
don't know the answer to some question
that you need
uh from the customer
and uh and at that point you might go to
the product donor and say
i don't know should this look like this
or this should this button be green or
hot pink
and the product owner might be
sat with you it's a common uh a common
trope of of xp and scrum teams to have a
uh
you know a product owner sitting with
the team
and that technically means that that
availability that that time is is zero
perfect
or
you could have the product owner maybe
in the next room well at that point
you're gonna have to get up and walk
through maybe they're not there maybe
that chat gets a bit more
well that availability is a little bit
longer that lead time to getting that
answer is a bit longer
and then even worse maybe that product
donor is is in the next building and
what's more they're split between three
other
teams
and maybe the lead time
that they can get you that answer is in
fact
days
well what happens to teams then
well what happens is that the teams go
okay well i was working on a but i can't
finish a now because i don't know
whether or not he wants a hot pink
button so i'm just going to start on b
we'll just park that for now it's fine
it's it's in a branch it'll all be okay
git will help us merge it later then we
go to b
and uh and we start on b but then
obviously product owner is still not
back from his holiday so
oh now i'm stuck again
because i have another question so that
but that's okay i can just park that and
then i i start on c
and that keeps going
and i've seen that many
many times
so
the problem is is that availability is a
core one the other side of things that
we hear are things like inspirational
being able to to be the the
inspirational leader for the team
well i'm not sure about that i think
that can be valuable but i think that
the team can be
can share that inspiration around a
little bit more
okay
so
inspirational
available
um
these are some of the things we we hear
we hear frequently
we also have other uh other things like
being able to be uh decisive being able
to make all of those decisions like is
this gonna be a blue or a hot pink
button uh and it's important to be able
to do that uh to be really kind of clear
um
an important thing that that is uh tied
to being decisive is it's not often not
just being decisive in many
organizations actually what it often is
is also being empowered actually having
the power to make that decision
so i once worked on a project where
there were many many stakeholders but
all of these stakeholders were in
positions of seniority to the
product owner on the team
and as a result what that really meant
was is that this person in order to make
pretty much any decision on the project
whatsoever
had to get sign off from 20
separate individuals
all of which
had strong opinions about what color
buttons should be
there was the other side of this which
just compounded the problem that each of
those 20 individuals was split across
five time zones i think if i remember
correctly
which clearly
caused a lot of issues on the project
so
availability and actually being
empowered the product owner needs to in
fact own the product which means they
can take independent decisions on the
direction of the project in order to be
able to move things along it's all very
well
that they can be decisive but actually
if they don't have if they're not
empowered and they can't make uh they're
not empowered to make those decisions
um then all they're really doing is is
middle management just forwarding things
around
so decisive
available
empowered
inspirational
these are all lovely things
but a lot of the time
this seems like a bit of a fantasy
rarely
when we put all of the attributes of the
product owner we would love to have
have many people actually have the
experience
of working with
that product owner
and and that's a sad truth they seem to
be
a little
hard to find
so let's have a look at the uh the
official official definition of product
owner this is from the agile alliance
and was
up to date as of uh
as a a few weeks ago
i don't think it changed much recently
so the product owner
is a role
on the product development
team responsible for managing the
product backlog in order to achieve the
desired outcome
that a product development team seeks to
accomplish
so i really like this definition as it's
at a starting point it's kind of nice
you've got the product owner is a role
on the product development team they
don't
own
the product development team
and they're responsible for managing the
product backlog
fine
in order to achieve the desired outcome
that a product development team
seeks to accomplish now what i like
about this is that the product owner is
a member on the product development team
but the whole team
desires a particular outcome and seeks
to achieve that and the product owner
collaboratively with the team
is helping the team
is helping the team to uh
to accomplish that goal by managing
their their role in that is to help
manage this product backlog
so
what i really like about that is that
they are uh this is seems like a very
collaborative position
so
what's interesting here is the uh is
that this particular definition on the
the agile alliance page that i i nabbed
it from
um it has separate bullet points and
these bullet points kind of uh go to i
think attempt maybe to clarify the
position of product owner but uh well
we'll see see what happens here so so
the second bullet point is clearly
clearly
identify and describe the product
backlog items in order to build a shared
understanding of the problem and
solution with the product development
team
hmm well
i've got some issues with this
because
it seems to me by this definition
that
the po
is responsible for
identifying all the problems
and then defining the problems
and then solving the problems and then
communicating the problem and solution
to the team
which i guess at that point the team i
know go to the pub because the problem
is apparently solved
yeah
i have some issues with that definition
for obvious reasons
but but seriously
the main problem i have
with this definition
um is the word solution
the problem i have is that
we don't build a shared understanding
of a solution
we build the solution
the problem isn't solved until it's
solved
you don't and we should avoid using the
word solution until it's actually solved
it is not solved if it is currently on a
whiteboard unless the solution is in
fact a whiteboard
you know a an architectural plan of how
we're going to design the class
structure for this particular thing is
not
the solution
it is just an idea an experiment a
potential direction
solution
is something that you get to
it isn't something that you start with
so next next little bullet point make
decisions regarding the priority of
product backlog items in order to
deliver the maximum outcome with the
minimum output
so i used to think that maximum outcome
with minimum output was kind of
hilarious and sounded like something
that uh schwarzenegger would say
maximum outcome
um but i think the uh
i think that really as it happened that
that particular phrase maximum outcome
minimum output well minimum output is
seen or output is seen in this
definition as the work the amount of
effort essentially expended an outcome
being the valuable benefit what's value
was delivered
in order to uh in order to get this
so
actually that that bit i take less
issuance with but here's the thing
the product owner is going to determine
how the priority
of things and this is this is common you
know what decisions they're going to
make oh well they're going to make
decisions on the priority i how
important is feature a over feature b
which one should we do first
how does a product going to make these
decisions
well when i ask audiences this question
i get
a range of answers but normally they say
well the
the uh the business
the business tells them what to do
the business
what's the business
the business that you mean the whole
organization they work for collectively
tells them what is important
no they mean the the business because
obviously the business is apparently
separate from the technology team that's
within
the business
i don't know to me that doesn't make any
sense at all the business the
organization you are one organization
most likely so what they mean maybe that
the customer well the customer it's i'm
talking about an internal team here
clearly as opposed to an agency customer
but the customer tells them that so
let's say the customer is i know their
manager okay well how does their manager
know
what to do
how do they know what is most important
how do they know how to make those
decisions oh i know there that that
could be the ceo of the company they're
guided by strategy the organizational
strategy tells them what way to go well
how was the strategy you come up with
how do we know that's the right strategy
and i can keep trolling
but
in reality this is a really important
question because you know what happens
when i keep asking an audience
how do we know how do you know how do
you know that's the right decision
eventually people go
and i can tell you
i imagine but there is a really
dreadful correlation between wind
direction and successful organizational
strategy this is not a valid thing there
is no strong correlation here
it doesn't work
wind direction isn't the ideal option
neither is flipping a coin or any other
form of vaguely
random direction selection
[Music]
the reality is is
most organizations
are not using
any form
of
sane
customer directed
decision
um decision making process so what would
that mean well we've probably all heard
the phrase user experience these days or
ux well ux
research as it's called
is a foundational concept well i gave
this talk um last year year before to a
room full of about 500 people and in
that room
and this is typical when i give this
session
i will only expect to see when i say is
user experience the guiding light is
asking the customer what they want what
they think is important whether or not
you solved their problem what problems
do you have
if talking to the customer isn't is your
actual is that actually your guiding
light is that your your true north for
death specifying your product direction
and strategy
i only see a handful of hands go up
and i think that's pretty common i can't
see all of you
i'm hoping maybe some of you are
throwing your hands up screaming at the
screen saying we do ux in our company
it's a brilliant idea
i hope that's happening
so determine whether a product backlog
item
was satisfactorily delivered
well what does that mean what does
satisfactorily delivered mean
delivered to spec
does it meet the acceptance criteria i
what is the definition of success
for a project well
if you uh got my vibe from the previous
uh the previous bullet point well
interesting
maybe
we should ask the customer if the thing
that we delivered solves their problem
maybe we should do that
but again many organizations don't
this talk is not about user experience
but
in reality
these things are naturally entwined
because as a product owner you are
making the decision as to what direction
you should take your product in
and if that's not driven by
uh customer need
and customer communication
then i have no idea how else you could
possibly be driving that
ensure transparency into the upcoming
work of the product development team
[Music]
oh this is a fun one
so i often get i often ask this i don't
really understand this so so previously
uh we looked at that earlier definition
we identified that by the definition it
says that the product owner um is on the
team and uh and the team collectively
are going to uh they desire to take the
product in a particular direction
so they're gonna to drive the product
forward they're gonna decide the goals
collaboratively
well
if
ensure transparency into the upcoming
work i'm guessing upcoming work is the
backlog because i'm not sure where else
the work would be
um
well if we're gonna ensure transparency
into the upcoming work
well surely the backlog and part and the
contents of the backlog was defined and
agreed collaboratively with the team
so why would you need to ensure
transparency of that isn't it already
transparent
isn't it already available
um
and then i i've had a i had this
conversation which goes something along
the lines of
product owner well i mean i wouldn't
want the uh
the the team to see everything i mean
they would just get distracted
distracted what what do you mean by by
distracted well you know i mean if they
could see like six months of work i mean
i've definitely got i've got that in my
pipeline they're all on my desk in cards
they're all in jira
all 25 000 of these stories they're all
in jira we've got plans for for years
but if they could see them that they
would just start developing stuff
they would just start what just randomly
pick something from the bottom of the
list
yeah because you know some of that stuff
is uh is more fun maybe
oh
really so you think the engineers i mean
have you ever seen that you ever has
anyone has anyone ever seen that ever
ever seen an engineer just randomly
start working on something literally at
the bottom of the backlog because it
seemed like it was more entertaining
well i don't know i i've definitely seen
engineers uh prioritize things that
might be more challenging or more
interesting to work on um but
really rarely do you ever see massive
massive changes
in priority
taken by a team member uh it happens but
that you've got separate challenges
there this isn't just a symptom of an
engineer engineers don't just randomly
start working on whatever the hell they
want
um just because because it seemed
interesting
um
and then
and then that's the other the other kind
of uh
the other question here is is that
in reality whenever i've seen situations
with apparent priority problems oh why
are they working on that that's not
important those kinds of issues well
in reality those issues
really most of those problems are no one
has any idea what the priority is
anyway nobody really knows what's the
most important things the most important
thing is is normally
whichever thing
the product owner has most recently been
shouted at
about by their customer or his manager
or something else
and that could change by the hour
depending on what company you're working
in
so
how do we know what to do
or another way of putting it where does
the work come from
and as we were saying before
we really often
in many organizations are still
essentially guessing
we guess as to what's most important
a fun one when they're not using the
customer a fun answer i get and say how
do we know what to do how do we know
what's most important is uh
oh we are we we follow our competitors
well i like that i like that idea
because obviously every organization in
the world
key recommended top up their business
strategy is to be
just that little bit behind
all of your competitors because that's
gonna be uh that's gonna be great who
needs innovation we want to be just just
there
we're happy with that position
maybe some advantages to that who knows
um
so really when we are looking at
how we know what to do
most of the time
if we're not going to the customer
directly and saying what's working what
isn't what you need
then we're often
not great
at knowing what to do
in fact
we're we're really
pretty useless
this is uh a little uh
taken from a study called exceeding
value from an organization called the uh
the standish group who also make a thing
called the chaos study that people might
have heard referred to
uh before
the interesting thing here um is if you
can see the
the uh
the chart
what this tells us and what they were
looking at was um
i think about a thousand uh
organizations and this they were looking
specifically at software created kind of
internal bespoke software so custom
order management systems and the like
um so bespoke software delivered to
large uh organizations
and what they were doing was comparing
the original um the features that the
engineering teams believe they delivered
with
their features that the people that use
the software every day
um
uh you know the things they use so
they'd say how are you using this
software oh i do this and i do this and
i do this and what features do you not
use but are aware of
um essentially how often do you use
those things
um
and what was interesting was that the uh
like that it's a really really
difficult thing to measure
um so we can assume a really
high error margin on on this data
because it's it's pretty difficult
to measure these things effectively but
even taken with a high error margin
80 percent of delivered features hardly
ever or infrequently
infrequently used
as a pretty stark judgment on the
software industry's ability to just know
what our customers want
without talking to them
so this is all pretty depressing
what can we do to improve this what can
we do well the most important thing
is
but i'm not gonna tell you yet
um we're gonna leave you hanging there
and uh and what i'd like to do is jump
back to
the uh
about a century ago
this guy
is a guy called frederick winslow taylor
who many will have heard of certainly if
you uh
if you took uh did any kind of mba or
anything like that
so this guy is an early 20th century
humanitarian
he uh this is a little quote
he's known for the high regard in which
he held his workers the uh you know the
ordinary pig iron handler
is not the type of man well suited to
shoveling
he is too stupid
there is too much mental strain too much
knack required of a shoveler all right
so he's not a humanitarian
he uh
but but he was
he was
more he was a scientist
and
he was more than uh the inspiration for
traditional management everywhere
what we tend to forget or perhaps ignore
is that taylor was actually one of the
first people to really popularize
the empirical method
in business
so what what did taylor do let's have a
look
so
taylor um was working in a
in a metal working factory
roughly at the turn of the century
and he wanted to improve efficiency
so he he started by breaking down every
process
into its component part so if you
imagine a metal working factory they're
going to be producing whatever like
sheet metal or
nuts and bolts or let's say metal doors
for the sake of example
um
and
and there's going to be a process like
melt the uh shovel the coal into the uh
pig iron um
into the furnace
melt down the pig iron et cetera et
cetera okay
and a particular area that he had a in
his in his um tome of greatness
the his books on scientific management
as he called it
um
they he focused a lot on on shuttling so
he broke down the process into its
component parts and then what he did was
he went round the factory floor
and he measured everything
to a hundredth of a minute so how long
does it take
each of the uh each of the stations and
obviously there were they're not just
one big iron shoveler in a factory there
could be there could be an a number of
them
so he he looked at each one and he timed
every single one this is what actually
referred to as a time and motion study
so he measured all the different
stations across the floor um
and worked out what the timing was but
but to his horror
um
there was massive massive inconsistency
across the factory floor
each of the workers were doing the same
jobs but but differently
i mean would you believe it they
considered themselves to be craftsmen
and for goodness sakes craftsmen and
each of them had their own approach and
style of work that was handed down by
their granddad who used their grandad's
ways who used their dad's ways
and some used different tools some used
a very variation on the process
so you've got
bob over here who who likes to shovel
the pig iron like just with his arms
like this just like that and then you've
got mike who uses the shovel that his
mum gave him for christmas and then
you've got bob who kind of uses two
trowels and does like a double troweling
action
well
that's great but there was such
variation
so his idea was to identify the one true
way for each process the most efficient
empirically demonstrated most efficient
method
which he would discover and then dictate
to the workers and show them the right
way to do it
why would they possibly want to do it
the wrong way
so how did he discover that the one true
way
well
we've got
the uh so
what do you what did he know uh he
looked at what he knew currently
what do we know currently about uh about
the thing okay well we've got bob doing
it that way and mike doing it that way
okay well he then formed a hypothesis
okay that hypothesis might be oh maybe
if i make a small change maybe it seems
that that mike with the shovel his mum
gave him for christmas
is uh is better than the others a bit
quicker so what if they all used that
shovel instead what if they all did it
that way
so
he then made a small change and he would
insist that the workers uh do it in that
particular way
in an experiment
and you go around and time everyone
again
and this is him testing
that hypothesis
this is then demonstrated this and
demonstrates the validity of that
hypothesis
which produces
learning
which he learns from now what's
interesting is and really important here
is that sometimes this invalidated his
hypothesis
sometimes
it proved that actually he was wrong
they weren't any quicker when using
mike's mum's
shovel
but either way
there was learning
and this new information is fed back
to make more hypotheses
and the cycle continues
and this
is a thing
known as
continuous learning
this created an environment of
continuous learning which is a
catchphrase for for the modern world but
interestingly in taylor's situation
this this led
to drastically increased efficiency
because there was this continuous cycle
of improvement
we talk about things like continuous
improvements and these are phrases again
modern catchphrases
but
this started here
now on the other hand he also triggered
a whole number of workers strikes the
more experienced workers feeling they
lost their individual style and
expression
which he was obviously suppressing
this environment of continuous learning
that he created
was limited to the upper echelons of the
organization the only people in taylor's
view with and i quote the mental
capacity
for this planning work
but then again he did see
dramatically increased deficiency
so what was he missing
he would seem to be on the right track
but he was missing something
so let's fast forward a few decades and
find out
so at about the same time that aretha
franklin was singing uh this classic on
the other side of the pacific there was
another movement underway
so
this guy
there's a chat called tai chi oh no and
between 1948 and 1975 him and eg toyoda
developed the toyota production system
which uh
later became lean manufacturing in the
us and eventually led on to lean
software engineering as many people be
familiar with
now he had a somewhat different attitude
to uh workers than
then uh then our friend taylor
uh this is a nice quote from him people
don't go to toyota to work
they go there to think
so i guess he he imagined that his
workers had some some mental capacity
so
in 2001 toyota racked up its philosophy
and values
and manufacturing ideals into what it
called the toyota way
and there are 14 principles grouped into
two key areas
now this talk isn't about toyota or lean
principles for that matter and i'm not
going to go into everything here but i
really highly recommend that you do if
you search for the toyota way you can
find this online the wikipedia page for
it's excellent
there's a bunch of material and
fantastic material available through
toyota all of this stuff is open and
available
um what i normally do at this point but
really struggled to get the audio to
work effectively over um
over zoom
was the uh
i'm just checking oh there we go sorry
my uh my picture my little monitor froze
for a second there i wasn't sure if you
could still hear me or see me for that
matter um so the uh
what i normally do is play a video at
this point but i really struggled to get
that to work through zoom effectively so
we're going to go into it go into it
separately on each on each point so
what is the toyota way as i said it
breaks down into into
14 principles that are grouped into two
key areas
what they call their pillars the two
pillars of the toyota way are continuous
improvement
and respect for people
needless to say
maybe one of those
is perhaps what taylor might have been
missing
so continuous improvement this is their
constant effort to improve their process
and reduce waste
they achieve this in a number of ways in
some ways seem familiar from our our
earlier exploration of taylor
so
become a learning organization with
hansai which is known as reflection and
kaizen
process of becoming a learning
organization involves criticizing every
aspect of what one does
nothing is sacred they constantly
reflect on practice and look into ways
of improving their approach
they have a well-known uh suggestion
system of toyota
which is a good example of this kind of
continuous improvement process
and the toyotas uh are encouraged to
make suggestions to reduce waste or
improve quality and they're actually
asked the question what is the smallest
thing you could do today that improves
the way you work
now toyota um last time i checked of
roughly 300 000 employees worldwide
and they've been running this system
since the 70s
amazingly
toyota get one
million suggestions year on year which
is incredible
and
what's more
is that
what's more is that uh
it is that that i mean think about that
that's like three roughly per uh user
per employee on average
um
and what's incredible is that is that
over 90
of those ideas
are actually implemented on an annual
basis
and one of the reasons for that is that
toyota as they describe it they
encourage action
action over uh overthinking
basically hopefully a combination of the
two but essentially don't just tell me
that you have a good idea go and do it
the employees and the people on the
floor are empowered to implement those
ideas
this is because they respect
their frontline staff
as the most qualified people in the
organization to make those suggestions
so nema washi building consensus so when
problems are discovered
they
they have this simple process that they
follow they head straight to the place
of the problem to see what's going on
now at toyota this is normally seen when
an employee pulls what's called the
andon cord
so the andon cord is a literally a
normally a stripy yellow and black rope
that runs all the way above all of the
stations in the factory and if you're
working and you notice a problem you
notice a quality problem you notice an
issue you reach up and pull this chord
and
the uh and the the you literally stop
the whole line and that sets off an
alert which then allows the uh allows
everyone to kind of focus in and know
exactly where the problem is they're
going to have a conversation so normally
because the line has stopped everyone
gathers around and they have a
conversation to try and identify what
the underlying cause is
they consider a broad range of
alternatives by pulling in other staff
if they need to the line is stopped so
everyone's everyone can focus obviously
and
they then build consensus on a
particular problem
on a particular potential idea for how
to fix this or an
experiment they're going to try and
what's really important here is they
don't just come up with an idea of um
like what they're going to do but in
each case they have to discuss how will
they know it's done
what's the end game how do i know that
that thing that i want to improve that
quality problem is fixed is it as simple
as well a machine will switch on again
or is it something more um
nuanced like a performance change i
think we can improve the performance on
this you know this station by 10
how do we measure that
after taking the time to come up with a
proposed solution they always go for the
thing they go and do it quickly they get
in there fast
and get mistake get the line back up and
running
and then once there is consensus around
that solution
it is then built
into what they call standardized work
so
oh wait a sec let's go back
ah well i'm going to talk about
standardized work while that little
joyous uh animation plays out so
what's amazing about this is
standardized work well that sounds a lot
like taylor stanite's work sounds a lot
like what taylor is doing and talking
about because actually it's a really
good idea for workers at different
stations to work in similar ways
um it doesn't make sense for all of the
workers to work in different ways it
doesn't make sense in software for us to
do things in a thousand different ways
we support and use things like you know
coding styles linters all of these tools
which essentially help us work in
consistent ways because there is benefit
in doing that
but standardized work is actually seen
as
i'm seeing if i actually have ah slides
gone missing there we go and
standardized work
for at um
toyota is actually seen as a an
empowering tool this is not a way of
working which is dictated to the
employees it's a record of the consensus
it's a record of how we are working
collectively
dick tart to tell them how to work
and standardized work at toyota is
absolutely foundational
so in this case we've got a little uh
factory scene here
stuff's been working and if you notice
behind me the line suddenly stopped
um because
this dude here
if i'm trying to point at things in the
green screen um thing this dude here
noticed that it was uh that there was a
quality problem there seems to be a
little notch in his box
so as a result his manager they wear
wheelies as well i think we i think
they're called um glides over to uh to
and says what what's up
um they then
uh look at that and they they have some
ideas on what might that might be but
actually what's going to happen here is
the manager is going to be questioning
the
uh the employee because they come at
this problem from different perspectives
the manager has this big picture of you
the employee is the expert of his
station
so
they're going to have this conversation
uh well what do you think it might be
well i think it could be that are you
sure it could be that i think that
probably looked okay and that's because
they have that that those different
perspectives which point maybe they
decide it might be jenny's fault over
here so they come over to jenny and they
say what's up seems like there's there's
this little dent in the uh in in the box
that's going that's going downstream and
they all look at the thing together oh
well look actually there's the problem
right there
at that point they come up with an idea
how are we going to fix this how are we
going to stop this from happening again
how are we going to improve quality
right here
and then they continue
that goes into any changes to the ways
they need to work go into their
standardized work
so now they've found a potential
source of the problem the manager asks
yeah what can we do about this and there
we go standardized work
so actually the standardized tasks and
processes as they described them they
describe them as the foundation for
continuous improvement and
employee empowerment
so
they talk about this relationship
between the manager and the employee
as
as a core thing this this mutual respect
i respect as the manager your close-up
knowledge and ability and dedication to
solve the problem
and as a team member
i respect your as the manager to the
manager i respect your big picture
perspective that allows you to ask the
tough questions that guide me to a
solution
so if you didn't get it already i said
that there was a superpower i said the
top thing the thing that we really need
to do
and i didn't tell you what it was
well unsurprisingly
we need
to collaborate
we have to work together
so
let's tie this together let's think
about how we might make product
ownership less of a one-man show or a
one-person show
so you start by bringing a hypothesis to
your team an idea that might solve the
problem or bring you closer to a goal
the team's job is to figure out the
simplest way the minimum output to
validate or invalidate this hypothesis
and they do this with an experiment
this provides learning and that learning
is the outcome the team have not failed
if they invalidate the hypothesis
learning is the outcome here and
learning will always get you closer to
your goal knowing what doesn't work is
just as important as knowing what does
as you learn more you'll be able to have
more certainty in your hypothesis or as
the scientific community call it
consensus
so you build a consensus around product
knowledge
as as a whole team collectively
no one
becomes the
one source of knowledge the knowledge is
distributed collectively around the team
so with that inspiration in mind i
created my own pillars of collaborative
product ownership
pillar pillar
one respect people you respect people
don't bring your team solutions to
implement as a product owner show them
that you respect their ability to solve
the problems you bring them
it's literally their job
embrace uncertainty
don't bring them solutions bringing
someone a solution is fake certainty
bringing a solution
is saying that we already know how to
solve this problem well you know what in
reality you probably don't you think you
know how you have a solution you think
you know how to solve this problem but
you don't have a solution until it's
solved
and what's worse is creating fake
certainty
around the uh around a thing
around a potential solution to a problem
that fake certainty not only
not only increases the risk because we
don't actually accept the inhere the
inherent uncertainty that's right in
front of us
but also
it reduces the opportunity for
serendipity because we pretend we know
everything we're not looking for the
other directions for the opportunities
and those opportunities might be just
what give your product the edge in a
competitive marketplace
so how do we overcome the uncertainty
well we accept that there is uncertainty
we accept we don't know
and we use small experiments working
with the team
that will gradually build
a shared understanding
of the problem space throughout the team
and then continuous learning with every
experiment
brings us learning
even if it invalidates a theory
and learning will always move you
towards your goal
even when it seems you haven't moved
shutting down
all of the paths that you don't want to
go down is
as important if not more important a lot
of in many cases
than just finding the right one all the
time
and then no complacency
allow consensus to build naturally
across the team but ensure it is safe to
question
everything
even the things that seem certain
especially
the things that seem certain don't get
complacent
so
product owners can respect the people
on a team by collaborating with them on
solving problems
and embracing the uncertainty of reality
teams can overcome uncertainty
with small experiments to test their
hypotheses which leads
to continuous learning
and builds consensus on the validity or
invalidity of a theory
but no team should ever be complacent
with the present state of understanding
and it should always be safe to question
anything
however certain
it might seem
so at the beginning we had a little chat
about
the single ringable neck
the
one throat to choke
you see
in a team where everyone is the product
owner in a team where
decisions are made by consensus
collaboratively based on a shared
understanding of the strategy and
direction
in those teams
everyone is a member of the team it's
easier to be a team member it's easier
to collaborate it's easier to work with
everyone
when everyone is taking responsibility
themselves and no one is being made
accountable
so
to the product owners out there that are
thinking about maybe moving to becoming
more collaborative
what i say to you
is
welcome to the team
and with that
i thank you very much for your time
and i think there's probably about am i
right five minutes left for any
questions if people have them i'll see
if i can
pull up the chat
if people want to ask i can see the chat
now so people want to use the chat in
there
in zoom or can i don't know if they can
send questions to uh
uh through to someone who can ask me
them i know people are looking on
youtube and other places
slack yes like i can't see like oh i can
i could only see oh yeah i'll go to
slack i'll pull up the slack channel
wait let's see would they are there
questions in slack that you can see i
have to use it on my phone
apologies
let's have a look
oh there we go
yeah
yeah well
i i can cope with that thank you very
much uh do feel free
we've got like i don't mind standing
here i could stand here just really
stoney face for a few minutes and see if
questions appear in the uh thing i'm
you're more than welcome i will hang
around in the uh in the slack channel
and around and slap generally um
uh throughout the day um throughout the
next few days so feel free to to hit me
up on there and ask me any questions um
you could
oh there is is that oh in the chat chat
in the other chat ah there we go the
product owners
usually come from i.t or the departments
we make software for
um
well okay well
it depends on how you see the how you're
organizing your your organization
because we tend to have this kind of
weird
uh thing i think i highlighted that
earlier in the talk there the the it
teams say oh the business there's the
business and then there's ideas if
somehow they are divorced with one
another um
my
my feeling would be that the the product
owner is a team member okay so
they are a team member and they are part
of the team they're not a uh they
shouldn't be ideally separate to the
like they are separate from the customer
there's nothing wrong with having um an
actual customer like the an actual
person from those teams embedded on your
team as well who's responsible for as an
additional sme and someone there but the
product owner is normally um somebody on
the team now i would advocate that there
isn't uh someone with the title product
owner on your team at all actually um i
would say that the role is best filled
by
individuals who perhaps you might call
sme subject matter experts people that
really know the space a good example of
that was i worked worked for a number of
companies in the kind of finance sector
um one was a
company that was producing an app that
allowed you to see like what your
current um pension
value the value of your pension plan was
um and like the estimated amount and how
much you could save and update it all
now all of that stuff is that's
obviously really very domain specific
like unless you're in that field of
finance which many engineers aren't you
don't necessarily know how to make those
things so having a good sme there who
could advise and work with the engineers
on that getting the calculations right
things is obviously critical and they
also knew they were also the product
owner so there's an example of like a a
role like a good role of somebody with
expert knowledge but i would say that
normally
um the product donor is someone on the
team is a team member within your
traditional it organization if that's
what you've got but ideally your
organizations are not necessarily
structured around those
functional
boundaries
um the uh so you end up yeah
so they're not they're not going to
structure around that all right uh we
have a minute left
i'll happily stand here for a minute
yeah absolutely no problem
all right then
well thank you very much again uh feel
free to to hit me up in any any channel
you find i'm relatively googlable so
you can uh you can harass me online
if i've said something offensive
um
thank you very much
by
hi everyone and welcome to my talk going
fast and cheap with boss sanity and
kubernetes
my name is ulla newber i'm a senior
consultant and partner in novanet
for the last couple of years i have
worked for two hotels and some of the
technology i'm talking about here today
are things we are using in their systems
on my spare time
i love playing games and mmo games in
particular for quite some time now i've
been playing world of warcraft classic
this talk is not about the game of
course but i will use a tool i made for
my guild as an example to show how we
can use some in my opinion pretty cool
technology to go really fast
when developing this tool i did not want
to spend too much time on the coding i
wanted to go fast
and being a hobby project
it had to be cheap
and being
and i selected discord
a voice and chat application for the ui
implementing a sp based chatbot
kubernetes to run the bot and finally
for the data i chose the headless cms
sanity
but to set the age and make sure you all
understand what i'm building a few words
about
what will
warcraft is all about
you create a character then you enter a
huge
and play the game for a very very long
time to level up your character and to
make it stronger and finally you will
reach max level
and you are ready to start for
what for many is the real
which is raiding
raiding is an activity where 40 players
venture into some specific area of the
game where there are particular hard
monsters that the 40 players need to
cooperate and coordinate coordinate
carefully to be able to successfully
defeat
raiding in world of warcraft classic is
a lot
organizing that is making these 40
people work together
voice communication is considered a
necessity to be able to make this
coordination happen
that is we need to be able to speak to
each other to communicate fast and well
enough
a headset with a microphone card
voice and text chat application not too
different from slack or teams is very
commonly used when raiding
to be able to routinely gather 40 people
to do this raid
most players join other players in
guilds
and this is another area where the need
for organization
comes in
there are typically more than 100
players in such a guild
each of these players can learn
different professions
a profession give the player
the ability to make
things that can be essential for raiding
what
such a profession is
alchemy
the ability positions and elixirs that
are really useful in raids to be
successful as a group it is really
helpful to have knowledge of what
resources are available to the guild
what can the different players do
so i wanted to make a tool where i could
ask
do you have someone to make this and
that potion who are they and then i can
ask them to help me out
so what i needed was a simple ui where
the gamers can search for crafters of
recipes
to make this happen i needed somewhere
to store the data i need
a ui for entering and editing of the
same data
finally i would need somewhere to run
this some sort of platform
my experiences from building this system
and my choices for those three building
blocks is what this talk is about
let's start with the data as this will
help explain
the requirements better
i didn't opt for a regular database for
this in fact my selected tool was sanity
cms
sanity is a headless cms system and in
my opinion a wonderful product
yes it may not be built to serve as a
database but it has a strong emphasis on
the data model of your content as we
shall see it automatically provides a
very nice user interface for interacting
with the data as soon as we have the
model in place
to get started you simply use npm
install as shown here to install the
sanitic cli tools
and then you do a sanity in it and we
get a starter project
that will produce something similar to
this
here we can see
the sanity studio which is the tool that
we build to both
to to interact with our
data in in the database here we can see
i have defined
my
my different document types i have
players
that's the people
or persons
that are part of my guild
and each of these players they can then
have
one or more tunes that's the characters
that they are playing with inside the
game
if we look at one of these
documents or one of these tunes
we can see it has different fields of
various types
i have a text fields and i have
here a back reference a reference to
another document to the owner or to the
player of the
so owning this tune we have a switch
controls
for boolean values and we have drop down
lists which is really implemented as
strings with some constraints as we
shall see and here we have a list of
recipes
for the tunes the recipes that he can
make and this is then one
to many relationship in in our database
even if
sanity is
kind of like a document database we can
model
one-to-many
relationships between the different
document types
and the recipes itself can be seen down
here
with another set of fields
this
tool is then
deployed to this the sanity servers
using simply on the command line sanity
deploy that's all there's to it
and
and we then get this
user interface hosted at the sanity
servers but while we are developing the
tool and at the same time developing our
data model we will run
the same same user interface locally on
our own machine so here i'm on localhost
and i have
if you noticed i have removed the the
recipe and i will use that as an example
to show you how easy it is to add
something to the user interface here
so let's look at the code this is what
you get when you do that initial npm in
it the most interesting part is these
schemas folder
where we have the root document the
schemas defining the start of our
database model
it has
it is developed in regular javascript
mostly we define different objects
that will then define our database model
so my
types here from the create schema
function
the different types of my database i
have players tunes and some other types
and then finally the recipe that i have
commented out here
just to show you how how this works so
i
add the recipe back and we can see here
we used standard javascript import
statements to import the different
schemas for for the documents into our
mains let me save this
and we can see here on the recipe how we
define a recipe
i export it as a the default for this
module and give it a name and list it as
a document type
and here add a
icon just use any regular icon library
in this case i'm using react icons and
game icons to get this
scroll icon that we can see in the user
interface afterwards and then we list
all the fields of
the document and again we just use
simple javascript objects
object declarations to to list the
different fields so
name
with the type string we have a profi
profession and that was the drop-down
list that we saw earlier and this this
is then constrained to the different
allowed or the different professions
that are available in world of warcraft
so we have alchemy enchanting and so on
and
we can have number fields and boolean
fields and all all the the types that
you would expect in in a database
um
we saw that we had a reference from the
tune to a
list of recipes so i will also go in
here in the tune
um
definition and then add
the
an array
of
of recipes or an array actually of
references to another document type
which is the recipe the document type so
this is simply how we
then add something to our our model we
can then go back here uh i have i didn't
show that maybe i have started here in
my terminal i have started this sanity
local web server using just sanity start
it will then compile my files and
immediately
watch and also watch for any changes
that i do to my schema and immediately
update here the running
user interface to see this in in action
we can
go into a recipe here and here we see i
have intentionally made
an error um
i i don't want the
field name to be in nodes one two three
so let's go in and change that
um
find the
recipe
and find the notes field and here we
have the title title one two three
and
if you look carefully down here you will
see when i save this it will start
rebuilding
down there it starts compiling and we
can also see that the user interface
here is rebuilding and automatically
updating
so all of this
gives us a very nice experiencing
experience
developing both the the user interface
here and the model as the at the same
time um we can do customizations also
it's it's it's very flexible uh the tool
um
we can if we if we look the the default
presentation of a list of documents is
like this where we just list the
document
name then the main field
um
but if we want something different we
can easily
configure a different presentation
of the the document types
so we
have i didn't get that right
okay
let's skip that um
we will see here that in in the tunes
list i i list more attributes from
in in the main presentation here and
this is done using
the the preview
definition where i define
what should be used in the preview
presentation in the user interface where
i'll list the the different fields
where that
i'm using or i want to use or display in
my presentation of
the
tune type
and then i have a functional prepare
function where i can build up again a
javascript object consisting of tile
title and subtitle and then i just do
some string concatenations of the fields
here and then i get this
presentation in in my overview
so
um
applying all of this there's a database
and
they have
developed their own
query language they call it clock
again it's javascript based
so let's have a look at how we can write
grog queries
uh the most basic query is star that
give is give me all the documents
in the database and we can see here
right now i have five
500 524 database
and if you want to
constrain that a bit
we use
this
like this now i'm constraining
the result to just document
of
type tune
and we can run that and we should see
that we get fewer items back and yes we
get 14
documents back we can
even further constrain this
let's say i want to do a kind of
of join operation
so
i want to now get
all tunes
that have um
in their list of references to recipe
document they have one at least one
document with the name stone scale oil
this is how we do
a kind of
joints in
and there i got something wrong
yep i'm missing
uh
tick there and then
then we we got
our query and we can see we have
three
three tunes in my document database that
has this stone scale recipe
but we get a lot of different fields
back here also system defined fields
these
created art for the document and so on
and we may not want that so
we can then do a projection and select
only
the names i add then
or define the projection as a javascript
object with the name
that's the the name it will get in the
result and i want to pick the field that
has the title name and then we can see
we have a limited our list to just three
items and the names of these crafters
and we can do similarly here we can
also
display
fields from other objects so let me then
also display
recipes
but as we saw earlier the recipes is a
reference to another document type
so we only get that
friends
initially but if we then de-reference
that reference using the arrow
operator we can then go into the related
documents and
pick out
attributes from that document so now i'm
picking out the just the recipe name
from the
reference document and we get a list of
the crafters
and
a list of the names of the recipes that
these crafters can make
so back to the presentation
okay so we have seen that sanity helps
us go fast but is it cheap
you can certainly start out cheap i'm
using the standard plan which includes
three users of the management studio
which is enough for me and the request
quotas on on the api are quite
sufficient
but of course as your requirement
increases the price goes up as can be
expected from a commercial product
sanity is built and marketed as a cms
not as a database
uh the lines gets kind of blurry when we
talk about a query language and doing
joins of related related data and so on
but to be clear i'm not advocating for
dropping all your databases and use
sanity for everything
in my opinion it is best used for your
own content content that you want to
display on
be it
a web page mobile or any platform but
content that you own and want to display
to the world i would not store
transactional data or something like
that insanity
i
don't think that would make much sense
it should be used where it fits and it
is as cms
at heart
you should also keep in mind that access
control is limited in the free plan you
can define your data set as public
and that means it's open for read for
everyone
or private and that but then you need
a special token to access the data and
everything becomes private
um in the more advanced plans there
there's more there are more options but
it all depends on on your requirements
so the user interface
we were already using discord the guild
is already have an account there and use
it for both text and voice communication
and discord like most chat system
can be extended with bots
that can provide all kinds of
functionality
a discord bot provide the user
with a command line interface
immediately available to all the users
of my discord server there is no need to
ask them to install anything
a bot is simply an application that once
registered and authorized with discord
and on your disk or
discord server
then it can listen for certain keywords
in the text chat
when it sees a trigger word
it will pass the text do some processing
and send a reply that will appear in the
text chat
the processing in the bot does can be as
smart or as dumb as you want
the name bot may lead to thoughts of
very advanced ai and such but
a chatbot is really just something that
can accept commands and produce some
response it's entirely up to you
to define or to implement any
smartness in in your bot
in my example here i have a command
crafting
and the argument stone scale
this is then sent to the bot that will
do its thing in my case it will go to
sanity and do some lookup on the data
store there and then build a reply that
is then sent
back to the discord channel where it was
sent from
and
give
and reply with in my case who can make
this stone scale oil
and we see here we have the same three
tunes that we saw earlier
so my building blocks are now discord
where the user enters their command
which is then sent to my bot that goes
to sanity and looks up the requested
information for the user and display the
result in the the discord chat
discord has a very detailed and good
documentation on their rest api
but
sorry they have a oauth endpoints that
can be authentication and there are a
lot of features available directly
through their http api
but as mentioned i wanted to go fast
and i prefer to use the higher level
nuget package
discord.net which is a very nice library
that builds on top of the raw api
it makes developing a record bot just as
easy as developing a regular.net debia
web api controller
in fact the programming model is very
similar as we shall see
to do queries again the sanity api we
use another nuget package
sanity client the package is written by
myself it is a net client that takes
care of all the details of sending a
query to sanity and to do the json and
to do json serialize the
return json documents into
regular.net classes
let's have a look at what the bot
implemented using discord.net
with queries insanity looks like
so
here i have my
dot apple bot application
where i uh
it's just a net core
console application
with the many of the features that all
who knows and are used to.net core
development will
recognize
quite immediately
we
in this case i start with
registering all my types into
my
or into the dotnet core dependency
injection mechanism we don't have to use
dependency in injection but i like
using it so so i'm using it here
and calling this configure services
method
where
which we can see down here below and it
creates a service collection which we
know from net core development
otherwise
and call registered services and then
finally builds the service provider
let's have a look at this registered
services
so we can see the types that i'm
registering
here in my bot
i start out by calling the
extension method on the sanity client to
register
my sanity database it needs a project id
and a data set and a token to identify
the the correct connection to to my
sanity
database
then i
add the discord
classes first we have some library
standard library classes and then
finally the command handler which we
will look into
in just a second
and then i will add a different
repositories and a query
which will then use the sanity client
that we registered to do the queries and
and get data from sanity
so let's head back first to
our main
and we have then registered our types
and we do then immediately we
resolve the discord client set up some
logging
and i do a initialization of my
recipe repository
and then we do the login towards the
discord
api
you can see here i read from my
configuration about token
when you start developing
discord bot you first need to go to the
discord pages and fill out some
registration of your bot anyone who has
done any any work on oauth
will
probably recognize this you
put in your name you
enter what what permission the bot
should ask for
when it is authorized in in a discord
server and you get back a client id and
you get back this bot token
that will um
be used as an identifier and it's very
important that you keep this bot talking
very
secret
because if someone else can
get to it then they can impersonate your
bot
then we start the the
the client which will then connect
to the
discord servers and i have a little
output here to the log we will
i will explain later in the presentation
what what we are doing here with this
log line
and then finally we install we call the
install commands async on the command
handler which was the third
class we registered for discord
here we simply set up the function this
is the main command handler for my bot
so we set up the function that should be
called by the library whenever there's a
incoming command from the discord into
my bot
and then i call the ad modules async
this will do auto discovery of all the
modules in my application modules can be
compared to any or to anyone who knows
any dot-net web api
controller development and a controller
and a module is very much the same or
similar concepts
um each of the the or the
command handling function
it's more or less boilerplate code
i am
i define here that i i'm looking for
anything that starts with a bang so
my
my commands should start with a bang so
that i don't pick up on
normal
chat if if the command starts with a
bang and then followed by my keywords i
will um will match it and reply and try
to reply on to it and then we just call
the the command
and as i said we we have these modules a
module is something that inherits from
module base and that makes it
discoverable by the
auto discovery that we started
earlier here
each of my modules should have a group
attribute
defining the main verb that we are
triggering on the other main word we are
triggering on so my bot here will
trigger on
bang crafter and then it will try to
match any of my command methods down
below here
each of the command methods is
identified by this command attribute and
they can then have different
um
arguments and
the discord.net
library will do
something similar to
model binding from controller apis and a
map any
and do the mapped
typing or
map strings to string arguments numbers
to numbers and and so on it has a
support for a number of different data
types
and it will try to call the the function
that cl most closely match whatever the
user typed into the user interface
um i have a breakpoint here in each of
my command methods
so um
if we then
quickly
start the debugger
we see here that it's starting up
just a second and it will
be running and it says it is ready
so then i go into the discord
application i have different discord
servers a discord server is similar if
you know
slack it's diff similar to a workspace
in slack it's more or less the same
thing
and uh in my
discord server here i have installed the
the bot and authorized it to
listen to
these commands so i type crafter of
stone scale
and
hit enter and we should then see yes it
then will match the because i typed
crafter recipe it will
or the recipe name it will match with
the first method here do some simple um
argument validation and then we do a
query against the sanity api
and
from the result from
sanity we build a text response then
that is then sent back to the
the channel where i
i type my command so we got back the
following craft stone scale oil i did
some
mapping here i
i read stone scale and then i will look
up in the available recipes and find
that stone scale oil is the one matching
or most closely matching stone scale and
then i get the names of the
crafters that can make me this stone
scale oil
same if i
here type crafter
let me spell that crafter
and stone
scale
and one two three so i have a number
then it should
break on the other method because it has
done this model binding and found that
there are two arguments a recipe stone
scale and the number one two three and
it will simply here just echo back
the
the risk
the the text or the values that i
entered so it will reply well you send
the recipe stone scale and number 123
so
we have seen that
developing a user interface using
discord
client is very very fast there's very
little code that we actually have to
write
we can focus solely on the business
logic
but is it cheap
yes definitely it is as cheap as it can
be it's completely free
so we have a system consisting of
discord a bot and sanity
both
discord and sanity are software as a
service and we don't have to worry about
running them at all they are running on
either on sanity or on discord servers
the guy in the middle
however the bot
he needs somewhere to live
kubernetes is my clear preference for
running services these days
and
yes some knowledge is required and it
may be overkill for the smallest systems
but going with kubernetes you know you
have a platform that can grow with your
needs
but wait you said
going fast and cheap
yes
a couple of vms are required to run a
kubernetes cluster but as we shall see
it's not that bad
i have msdn subscription with included
usher credits so choosing
azure was a no-brainer for me
there are many vm sizes on azure to
choose from but i have picked a smallish
but not too small vm the b2s i would not
go too small because each node in a
cluster
there's a fixed
amount of resources that will be used
for the system itself
so on a small server the percentage used
for this gets bigger
choosing the four gig
sized b2s looked okay to me i wanted to
squeeze it into my monthly included
credits so i opted for
two nodes in my cluster the recommended
however is at least three
but well it's a hobby system and it
seems well to
to work well enough with the two notes
however
you should be aware that region matters
both beer
and usher vms are expensive in norway so
make sure to check prices
in the
region you have selected before you buy
well
kubernetes is a huge
area that could easily fill
the whole talk alone
but there's one particular area that i
have used for my project that i find
very useful and i would like to share
with you
operating operating systems have used
the file and folder abstraction for
other things than just plain files for a
long time
by implementing a driver we can use the
file system
abstraction for other things we can
implement a driver that let us read
secrets from usher key vault as if it
were local files on our disk
each secret becomes a file in our file
system
completely transparent to the
application
usher adpod identity is another
service we can install in our cluster
using azure ad pod identity we can
connect pods with managed identity
as through it
and through this we can
control the access rights for each pod
to usher resources
such as keyboard
so i can say that
this pod these white brownish pods
should have these access
and
the blue one another set
and the green pod maybe shouldn't have
no access to the keyboard at all
combining the two we can manage access
to key vault and provide the keys to the
application running inside the pod
completely outside the scope of the
application
this ensures that the administrator can
be left to manage
this and the developer does not have to
do anything special in his or hers code
to the developer it makes no difference
if the code is running on his or her
laptop
or in a kubernetes cluster inside azure
the required service for mount mounting
of secrets in the file system is
dependent on your kubernetes version
if you are on version 1.15
or older you would use key vault flex
volume
if you are on version 1.16
or newer
the one you want to use is azure keyword
provider for
secret store css driver
let's see how we set up this
so
we stop
and
here we can have a look at our
deployment deployment manifest for our
bot pod
the part that
where we define the in integration with
the
key vault is here down below on the
volume mount we specify
amount path i want
that
the key vault secrets should be present
in the folder under the mount path kv
mnt in this case and i want a read-only
file system
i would then define in my volumes
section i would then file define that
i'm using flex volume here in my pod
and i specify a driver asher slash kv
i'm using a key vault my keyboard is
named kivo kivo
my name is
is midgar ki
and then i list the different secrets
inside this key vault and the names of
the secrets so i want to
have
a file for the discord token one for
sanity token and one for demo secret
here inside my
my pod
and when i then
deploy this to my cluster
it will
mount from the keyboard and map the the
name secrets from the key vault into the
pod and they will all be available and
the path that we specified in the
deployment file
so let's have a look at this
i have prepared some commands
first i'm running cubectl getpod to list
the pods
inside my cluster
we can see here i have
the midgard bot pod running
and let me then do a cube ctl
exec which will then run a command
inside the the pod and
specify the pod name
and then the command i want to run which
is
ls to list the contents of the kvmnt
folder and this will now run inside my
pod
if i can type the correct command there
so we see here down here in the terminal
i got the response back and in fact i
have three files the sanity token file
the bot token file and the demo secret
file inside these files we will now have
the the secrets from the keyboard vault
so i again run cubectl exec
name of the pod and then run the cat
command on the file demo secret inside
the key kv mnt folder
and we run that in our terminal down
here and we see that the contents of
that file and in fact my secret is this
is from the key vault
so
how do we then read these secrets in our
application
and let's go back to
the application here
and we use
standard.net core configuration
to or we can use standard.net
configuration to read these secrets
the
configuration system of.net core has
a number of different extension methods
that you can use
to provide configuration sources for our
our application in this case i'm using
add json file which you probably know
already
to add the app settings.json
source
and i use
user secrets that we will you be using
for local development
and environment variables and finally i
use the add key per file and the ad key
per file is designed exactly for this
purpose i think
where it can then read the folder i
specified again the kb mnt folder and
read
each of the files located in that folder
will be available to the configuration
system as a configuration setting
so
so now we know or you may
see why we had this console writeline
where we read from the configuration and
read a demo secret
and display that on startup of the
application
let's first look at how this would look
when we do local development i would
then use net user secrets
and set this demo secret to this is from
user secrets so we can see the
difference when running locally and when
running inside the pod
so i set that setting and i will start
my
my bot
which will then on startup type or write
to the console
the contents of the configuration
setting
and not too surprisingly
it works to read from user secrets and
we see here demo secret is this is from
user secrets
we can see then how the exact same code
when it's uh deployed to kubernetes will
then use the last
config source
it all it works configuration works like
that that always the last configuration
source is
used if the same setting is in several
places so in the cluster it will always
use then the
add key per file
extension method if the
secret is present on that value so we
can then use if we go back here
and to the terminal
and have a look at the logs of the
running
pod inside my cluster using cubectl logs
and the name of the pod and i pipe that
into less so that i see the beginning of
this log file and it should then read
demo secret this is from the key vault
so we see that the exact same
application
works without any modification to the
application it works when running
locally and it works inside
kubernetes without us having to
write any special code that knows
anything about
key volts usher kubernetes
anything it just
uh use these very simple abstractions
and reads from
the file system and the administrator as
long as he configures everything
correctly for the application to run
everything will just work and we have a
very clean separation of concern
so
oops
if i can get back to the presentation
there
okay
so to summarize
for the ui i used discord and bots which
is a quick way to get a user interface
in place without getting in distracted
from the pure functionality
for the data we used
sanity which automatically generates the
management ui for us
saving us a lot of work and it's really
quick to get up once you know the tool
and for running the bot we used
kubernetes that provides a great
platform that allows for growth and
mounted
secrets which is a great security
feature allowing
us to keep our secrets really nice and
safe inside keyboard
and while still allowing the developer
to
not have to worry about this
thanks a lot for listening
and now we may have a time some on for
some questions
if you would like you can then go to the
slack channel for conference room one
and we can see
and i will try to answer
any questions should there be any
so
well
if you write something later then i will
of course try to answer that then but
it seems we are done and well thank you
all for listening and
have a nice day bye bye
hi everyone
thank you for joining this session where
we're going to talk about how we are
building an open source government
application platform in the cloud
we are three team members of the team
that is building the rt3 platform for
innovation digitalization agency the
team consists of member bot from the
agent itself and consultants from
different companies
my name is reunite russian and i work
for accenture technology
and i've been doing that since 2005.
i've been working on the altenew
platform since 2008 and i was part of
the team the original built the second
generation
i'm a developer and technical architect
and i do most of my coding in dot net
hi everyone my name is nina kilsta and i
also work at accenture technology and
i've been working there for the past six
years
and for the past five years i've also
been working on the ultim platform
i am a developer and technical architect
and i like to think of myself as a full
stack developer
but i do work mostly front end these
days
outside of work i have a one-year-old
who keeps me busy most of the time
and when i do have some spare time i'd
like to read
and i've also dusted off my sewing
machine in these times where we're
staying so much at home
hi guys my name is stephanie boidu
i've been with avenard and the alton
team since 2018.
on this project i've focused mostly on
the backend part of our solution and
also our integrations with alton 2.
in my spare time i quite like knitting
and that's a great hobby to come by with
combined with netflix so i do quite a
bit of that as well
so in this presentation we're going to
talk about what alton is giving you a
little introduction for you guys who
doesn't know that
we're going to talk about the project
archangel project how that started and
our
technical principles we are building a
new platform
and ago we go into details about the new
platform the components and the solution
we are creating and then we are going
through the cloud architecture and
components we are using as part of the
solutions you know give you the current
status and what we will do working on
next at the end we open up for questions
so please ask questions almost like if
you have any
so
what is alton
imagine you work for a government agency
that needs to get data from the citizens
of norway maybe we want them to report
their covert 19 symptoms
and maybe want a digital service online
where that can receive that data
then alton is the platform for you
alton is an internet portal for dialogue
between the citizens the businesses and
the agencies of norway
it's also a technical platform where the
agencies can build and host the digital
services
you can say that alton was one of the
first platform as a service providers
because it already started back in 2002
when three
agencies joined forces to build a common
platform for reporting to the government
and in 2003 the first generation was
launched in 2010 the second generation
went live
and during those years more than 50
agencies had joined the platform
including the armed forces the police
health and many more covering most of
the government sectors of norway
there are no more than a thousand
digital services available through the
platform
that's include everything from naming
your first born to report on aircraft
incidents almost all businesses in alton
in norway uses alton every year
and this as this diagram shows almost
everyone
from 13 to 110 uses altin every year
in orton everyone has their own inbox
where they find their communication with
the government
you also have a service catalog where
you can find your digital service and
what you need
having this common platform is quite
unique and it's regarded is one of the
reasons that norway is a leader in
digital government
another
good
functionality is that every
functionality is available through api
so there are lots of software vendors
have implemented integration with alt-in
so as an example can submit your tax
report directly from your financial
system
gartner regards alton as one of the top
five government technical platforms in
the world
so back again to the agency and the need
for having data from the government
you
what i'm just said maybe you think that
ultim2 is the perfect platform
but there are some limitations
we base the current platform on physical
hardware so even if our traffic varies
from hundred thousand a day to
2.5 millions a day we are scaled the
same
all year long
and as a agency today you will need to
make a digital service that is well
supported on mobile and on desktop but
we are using infopod and it's very
limiting and what you can do with that
in addition there is a limitation on
what kind of process flow you can
support for end users
it's quite time consuming to
do testing because every time you do a
little change you need to deploy to the
test environment
and version control is done through
sharepoint so it's very difficult to
understand what kind of changes you or
others had done previous on your digital
service
and when you're done testing you're
ready to go in production
in today's platform you need to get help
of a technician to deploy it
and those are some of the limitations
we are started building on the next
generation of artem
so this project started already back in
and we had at that time
time looked into what kind of product
could replace infobot
but we realized maybe we should try to
build something from ourselves from
scratch so we did a small proof of
concept at that time just verify are we
able to build a platform using asp.net
core
and we kind of yeah it's possible
and in 2018
we were ready to do a full-fledged
proofrun concept
uh we wanted to
build a new platform using.net core and
we want to use react as frontend we want
to use docker and kubernetes
and
in
in the spring of 2018 we started to
verify are we able to do this and during
the summer of 2018 we were saying okay
you were able to prove our main concept
that is we are going to build a ui
designer using react so
we then finalize the concept and getting
ready to start a minimum revival product
project and that is what we are
presenting to you guys today
so
what is our concept on the new platform
we will
let
the developers working for agencies
be able to
develop by themselves or as a group
digital services
deploy to production as containers
to a public cloud infrastructure
and all that without you needing to know
programming or not need to know anything
about cloud infrastructure
pretty cool so to do this new
platform we define some architecture
principles
and i'm just going to mention the five
most important ones
so we want to be open source we want
others to use our platform and
components
if they want other agencies want to use
it internally or maybe a different
country
and we also want contribution from the
agency that needs some features to the
platform
so all our code is available on github
all our issues are available on github
and we only use tools and frameworks
that are open source
the second principle is that we really
want
the platform to be loved
so we build with tools that the
developers like so we have chosen the
most load web framework according to
stack overflow react we are used using
the most load back-end framework that is
asp.net core
and we are using three more slot
platforms since we are using linux
containers
based on docker
and everything is
built around visual studio code that is
the most load development environment
we truly love working with our platform
and we believe that others will too
these are some of the tools
we have been using in our platform
the third principle for a new platform
is you're going to build everything as
microservice you want to be able to
scale independently the different
components you want to be able to deploy
them you want to be able to have teams
responsible for different components so
every component is deployed as a
microservice and all the digital
services are created and deployed as a
microservice
the fourth
principle is also very important for us
because we are going to end up with a
big infrastructure in the cloud
and we are not able to run that
by ourself if we're going to manage it
as a team so we favored using managed
services available in azure as an
example azure community service
stephanie will tell you more about that
later
and the last one
application owners will be isolated from
each other you don't want an application
to be able to affect the service for
others or be able to access data for
others so
we have isolated infrastructure for
every application owner and we also
isolated and separate data store for
every application owner
then nina is going to tell you more
about the solution we are building
thank you do that
all right
so uh we had our overall concept
and we had our architecture principles
and we had the proof of concept ready
and based on this we started building
our solutions
alton 3 is made up of three solutions
that work together
first we have the alton studio solution
and this is our design time solution to
create develop and deploy applications
or apps as we call them
have the alton apps solution this is the
collection of all of the running apps
and the kubernetes clusters on which
they run
finally we have the altin platform
solution which provides the common
back-end functionality for the apps
so let's look now at how these three
solutions work together to support the
next generation of digital services for
the people of norway
so let's go back to this scenario of a
government agency that wants to collect
some data
and they want to create a digital
service to do this
and we'll see how we can solve this by
creating an app using the alton 3
solutions
now these are some of the key features
that we like that we want to support
and these are also some pain points from
the existing platform that we would like
to improve on
so what is an app in this context
well an app is a digital service in the
form of a standalone application
and this application exposes some apis
it has some sort of graphical user
interface and it runs in a docker
container
so to support this we have created an
app template
this is the starting point for all of
the apps
the app template is built is a
net core mvc application
completely standard and then we have
extended it with
some supporting libraries
these are projects that we publish as
nougat packages now nougat is dotnet's
package manager
and these supporting libraries contain
things like the standard apis that the
apps should expose
as well as integration with the altin
platform
we've also added placeholders for custom
logic and a set of configuration files
that the app developers can use to
configure the apps
the app also refers to a front end this
is a react application that is loaded
from a content delivery network at
runtime
all of the apps use the same front-end
by default
and the front-end can then be configured
to work with the specific apps
the front-end integrates with the app
itself via the apis that the app exposes
so let's look a little bit at how an app
developer could actually
customize the app
as i mentioned
one of the ways to do this is through a
set of configuration files
one of the most important configurations
that we set up is the process the
process defines the
set of tasks that the end user that
actually uses the app must go through
so for example if we look at i think
back in our scenario
of a government agency that wants to
collect data
so the end user might have to for
example fill in a form this would be a
data type task
they might then have to confirm that
their data is correct so this would be a
confirmation task
finally they might need to wait for some
response from the agency that they are
submitting their data to and this would
be the feedback type task so these are
the three task types that we support and
they can be combined in any way to
create a process
now defining the process is done through
the process configuration file and when
we set up our configuration files
we tried where possible to use existing
standards for the format
for the process
we use the bpmn 2.0 standard this is an
xml notation for defining processes
we we've also used the zakumal standard
for our authorization policies
and this is an xml standard for defining
access control
now authorization policies can be
applied to the entire app as a whole
or to specific process tasks
so that was a little bit about
setting up the app using the
configuration files now the app
developers can of course also
customize the apps
through code
as i mentioned we set up
some placeholders for custom logic now
this is for things like validation
calculation or pre-filling of data
but this is really just the beginning
app developers can really do anything
they want as long as they can put it
into code
for example they could fetch data from
the alt-in platform or from external
sources
they could create and expose apis
and the list goes on and on and really
as i said if it can be coded it can be
done
now let's take this one step further
i said that the
apps all use the same front end by
default and then that front end can be
configured
well imagine that this doesn't cut it
you can't configure the standard front
end to do what you want it to do
all right
replace it with something different
since we just refer to the app front end
from the app you can just refer to
something else and load it at runtime
or
drop the front end entirely and have
your end users
go directly to the app via the apis
and if we go even further now
nothing is really stopping you from
doing the same thing with the app
template itself
you could if it doesn't work for you you
could replace it with something
different
maybe even a java application
now personally uh
i would not choose to
replace our
beautiful amazing.net app template with
a java application
but joking aside
if the standard template doesn't do it
for you
then of course it is possible to replace
it with something else
and we see that in the future we might
actually have a set of app templates
using different technologies
that can that you can choose from
when you are creating an app
all right so let's go back now and
assume that you want to keep the
app template and front end as is and
then just work on configuring it
now
as we um
as we've said before we want the uis to
be
modern and they want them to work on
both desktop and mobile
and one of the ways to configure the ui
is by creating a form
for collecting data
so as adriana mentioned we decided to
build our own tool instead of using
existing tools to do this
so we built it we built a drag and drop
forms editor using react
and this forms editor
has a library of available components
that can be dragged into the form layout
and then configured
now currently we only support very
simple forms with a single column layout
and we do aim to expand on this
when
an app developer works on developing
on configuring a forum like this
the
actual form configuration and the
definition of the form is stored in a
json layout file so this is our form
layout file and it defines how the form
should look
at runtime
the app frontend then parses this
layout file
and renders the form
now
this
configuration is for the data type tasks
so forms are for collecting data but we
do have the possibility to configure
views for the other task types as well
so that would be confirmation and
feedback we have views for these
and the app owners can then configure
the content that will be shown in these
views
now so far i've talked about the apps
but how do we actually develop
apps into complete digital services
well this is done in the alton studio
solution
alton studio is made up of three parts
and we have the designer application
this is the graphical user interface
that app app developers use
to create and develop their apps this is
what it looks like
in the designer application we have
things like the forms builder that i
just showed you and we have an editor
for setting up texts for language
support and we have some
support for simple code editing
using an embedded code editor and of
course deploy
now the designer application integrates
with the repository application this is
where all of the apps in alton studio
are stored
the repository application is built on
gitti
this is an open source code hosting
solution that uses git
and it looks like this a little bit like
github
now each app in alton studio is stored
in a git repository and when an app
developer works on an app in the alt in
studio solution
they are working on a clone of the
central app repository
and when they're done with their changes
they could push their changes to the app
repository
now this makes it easy for multiple
developers to work on
the same app at the same time
and all of the files are version
controlled just like normal source code
we have set up a load balancer to route
between the repository application and
the designer application
based on the url that
comes in
now building
applications through a graphical user
interface and drag and drop it's cool
unfortunately not all of the
functionality of the apps is supported
to be configured
through a graphical user interface in
alton studio
in addition some developers might
actually like to use their own tools
especially when it comes to writing code
so we support local development
where app developers can use their
favorite tools to work on the apps
so once an app is created it can be
cloned to your local computer and where
you can work on it
once you're done you can push it back up
to the app repository
for deploy
now one very important aspect of
developing an app which i haven't talked
about yet is testing
apps needs to be tested
and the apps need uh the alton platform
solution to actually run
so one possibility is to deploy the app
to a test environment where the alt-in
platform solution is running however
if you are
just testing
while you are developing and testing
incremental changes
this could be very time consuming
so in order to support local testing
we have created a platform mock now this
can be downloaded and run in parallel
with the apps
in order to actually test the apps
locally on the fly while developing
this platform mock is also used a lot by
the development team when we're
developing new features for the apps
all right let's look at deploy
apps are deployed from the alton studio
solution to a kubernetes cluster in the
alton apps solution
now as eduna mentioned
each app owner or government agency
has their own kubernetes cluster to
which they deploy their apps
and this is true for both
test environments and production
this means that the apps of one agency
do not affect the apps of another agency
and this is what allows us to
provide self-service deploys all the way
to production
now deploy is a two-step process
first
we need to actually build the
application
and this builds a docker image for the
app
and then pushes it to an azure container
registry
and this is done via an azure devops
pipeline which you can see an example of
here
once the build is done
we can deploy the app to the environment
that we choose and this fetches that
docker image and deploys it to the
specified environment again done using
an azure devops pipeline
and now arjuna is going to show you a
little bit about the altin platform
so the ultim platform is the part of our
new platform that contains all the
functionality needed by the apps we have
grouped the functionality into different
containers or microservices
and and
are those are available through apis and
the first component is the
authentication component
and that's responsible for
authenticating user and system wanted to
accessing an app
the component work as an identity
provider for apps and this again is
integrated with other external identity
providers like the national id port in
norway
doctorization component
is authorizing access for every apps the
apis and so on and this this is a
sacrament 3.0 policy decision point
that reads the policy file defined as
part of the application repository just
mentioned by nina
so
every app will call the authorization
point and we'll
get a response saying if the user or
system can exit or not
we believe that this component can be
used in others type of scenario it's
available in our source code and could
be used in every elsewhere you can use a
pdp
then you have the profile component
where it gets the user information for
users
you have the register component where
you find information about all the
citizens and the businesses of norway
often used in apps
we have
the receipt
component that provides uh receipt for
earlier communication with the
government and all those apps i
mentioned now are based on asp.net core
but pdf component is in fact a java
application
and the reason for that is that we were
not able to find a good enough open
source pdf tool for net so if anyone
else will build it we really truly
appreciate it
so
and then we have the received component
now sorry the
storage component
where you find
the storage functionality for apps this
is where the user will end up storing
their data this is also where the agency
will retrieve their data through apis so
when a user submit data in a wrap the
app will call this storage component and
it will be stored down to a separate
storage account in azure
so those are the components we have and
the next step is what kind of cloud
architecture are we building and
stephanie is going to give you the
details about that
thanks
so guys we're going to move on to talk a
bit about our public cloud components
and our architecture and azure we're
going to exemplify this by looking at
how we deploy our microservices
and so microsoft actually established
the first norwegian data centers this
winter
one placed east and one placed west in
the country
this makes them the only large cloud
provider with data centers in norway
given that they have two data centers
we're able to have redundancy within
norwegian borders
and this is great as we then can take on
application owners that have a
requirement that they their data be
stored within norway
another great thing about using the
norwegian data centers is that we get a
lower latency in the communications
between our on-premise and cloud
solutions
and so neil andrew now have told you
guys about are different microservices
so we have the different platform
components and we also have the apps of
our users and often studio
what i want to take you through is how
do we get from a bunch of code on github
or giddy
to running services online
the exciting thing here is that the
concepts that i'm going to show you
are the same we use whether we're
deploying our microservices or the
microservices of our users the app
developers
and so the first step of course is
source control
we use github for all the code that
we're developing
and giddy for all the code related to
the applications
at this stage we also like to run
analysis on our code
so we use lgtm looks good to me for
security analysis
and sonar cloud to ensure that we have a
maintainable code base and that's just a
few of the tools that we're using
and so once we have a new feature for
the platform
or an application owner decides it's
it's time to build their app
a build pipeline is triggered in azure
devops
and so this build pipeline is made out
of t ready template tasks in azure
devops making them really easy to
configure
it's a two-step pipeline where the first
step is building a docker image
and the second step is pushing that
image to container registry
container registry is hosted in azure
and this is where we store our live
images until we're ready to deploy the
microservice
and the two important things i'd like to
point out about the container registry
the first point being that
we are a public platform and our users
must be able to trust that their data is
safe going back to the isolation
principle
this is why we have a
container registry for each of our
application owners where only their
docker images are stored
secondly a single docker image might be
deployed to multiple environments so
both testing and production
this is why we treat our container
registry and all the docker images as
production resources
meaning that we set restrictions on what
and who is able to access the resource
as well as which availability we're
expecting and also which region we're
hosting the resources
so next step once we have the docker
image in container registry and we're
ready to deploy the microservice
is that we trigger a release pipeline
this is also hosted in azure devops
and this pipeline would use helm
to install the microservice on the
cluster
but i do have a confession to make
before we take a closer look at the
release pipeline
because we are an open source project
and we really like mentioning it because
we really like that fact
but truth be told we do have an
additional repository which is protected
and this is where we store sensitive
data such as helm charts and
instrumentation keys for some of our
resources in azure
and so this helm chart and the other
secrets are packed as an artifact and
included into the release pipeline that
way
what we see here is an overview of
the release pipeline for one of our
platform components
we can see that two artifacts are
included in the pipeline
the first artifact is to identify which
docker image we want to deploy
and the second artifact would be the
helm charts from that repository i was
just mentioning
so once we have the artifacts we're
ready to deploy this microservice to one
of our environments
and what we can see here are all of our
environments listed up
so in the first stage you'll find our
acceptance testing and load testing
environments
in the second
in the second stage we have the testing
environment for our application owners
and then finally we have production
and so for these various stages we have
different triggers
with regards to a platform component a
new release would go to the acceptance
testing environments whenever a new
docker container is available or a
docker image is available
for our application owner testing
environments and also production we have
weekly releases
and we also have some manual checkpoints
prior to each release to ensure that
that we have people at work in case
something was to go wrong
but the most important thing about this
release pipeline
is the tasks that it completes
and the most important task is that the
pipeline would
would run a helm upgrade or helm install
task depending on if the microservice
has been deployed previously or not
and the result of this task is that a
new pod will spin up in the azure
kubernetes services cluster
which brings us to the final step
so a new pod spins up in the kubernetes
cluster
and the referenced docker image is
pulled onto the pod and the microservice
starts up
and it's always ensured that the
microservice is fully up and running
before we terminate any pre-existing
versions of that microservice
this results in a deploy without any
downtime
and so this is our overall process for
good getting from code on github to
running services online
and again it's the exact same process
whether we're deploying our market
services or platform components or the
applications of our users
but let's take a look at how this looks
in azure once all the microservices are
deployed
so what we can see here is an overview
of how we've set up our infrastructure
in azure for our different solutions
starting with alton studio we can see
that this runs in a separate kubernetes
cluster
you can see the two services alt in
designer and ultim repositories
within altin studio you'll also find the
virtual network
we have a key vault where we store
secrets and certificates that are
accessible by the microservices
and we have an ingress route to control
the traffic onto the correct node
running the pods
and then we have a load balancer
to
to direct the traffic to the right
microservice again
and i think that's the other way around
sorry so the load bouncer
handles the incoming network traffic so
directing us to the correct node
and then the ingress route would direct
us to the correct microservice
we can also see the connection here to
the build and deploy or build and
release pipelines that are triggered by
our users when they're building and
deploying their applications through
alton studio
so the next component is alton studio
and i think this might be the most
exciting part of our infrastructure
so what we can see here are two examples
of application clusters
and they've each got four running
applications each
so when an application owner decides to
join our solution they're given two
azure subscriptions
one for their testing
resources and one for their production
resources
within this subscription you'll find the
kubernetes cluster where they host their
microservices or their apps
you'll find the keyword key vault for
sensitive data
accessible by the microservices
you'll find the virtual network the
container registry where we store the
docker images
and you'll also find the storage account
in this storage account we'll store all
the data collected through their
applications
and again we have the ingress route
to control the incoming network traffic
and the load balancer
and common for these apps is that many
of them would require the shared
platform
and so the communication to get from the
apps to the platform
has to pass through an application
gateway and then api management before
reaching our microservices
and so what we can see listed here
are our different services in the
platform
each platform component runs on their
own docker container
we do actually have quite a bit of
communication within these microservices
as well
especially to the authorization
component to authorize the different
actions
so this communication is enabled through
d
and we have an encrypted politi pod
communication
so this saves us from routing that
traffic through the internet and then
back to the same kubernetes cluster
i'd like to draw your attention to the
bottom component
platform storage
we can see that this component would
connect to cosmos db
or storage account depending on who owns
the data it's handling in a given
transaction
we also have our
connection to the on-premise environment
which is alton 2.
so this is enabled with with an express
route
and this gives us a high-speed
communication between our on-prem and
cloud solution
and so looking at this infrastructure as
a whole there's a varying level of how
consistent the components are
for alton apps for instance
we'll be having new service owners or
application owners wanting to join our
solution
or we'll have requests to upgrade some
other components
and of course we have the standard work
like
upgrading our kubernetes service
services cluster or our version of
application gateway for instance
and we've struggled a bit with finding a
good way to maintain our infrastructure
but recently we started using terraform
and terraform is a great tool as it
allows us both to provision and evolve
our infrastructure
and even better it's all written in code
that allows developers like us to take a
much larger part in both setting up and
maintaining our infrastructure
this is because we're able to read the
code and modify it to suit our needs
and so looking at this picture you can
see that there are quite a number of
cloud components involved in setting up
our infrastructure
and of course some parallels can be
drawn to technology that we've used on
premise but not always
and so when we've tried to select which
cloud components to use or how to
configure our virtual network for
instance
we've had to base our decisions on the
points that you can see here
and so i would say that the point right
at the bottom here
might be the most important one
so which components do we think have the
potential to evolve along with our
platform and the capabilities that we
expect to
deliver or offer in the future
and i think this says something about
daring to imagine what the future looks
like a dream about what we wish the
future might be
even though we don't have it right now
and in some cases it also means doing
the necessary work to make sure that our
needs and expectations are made clear
onto those that are further developing
azure
and so here we can see the most central
cloud components that we're using at the
moment
luckily a lot of these
components are fully managed by azure
this limits the number of variables for
us to tweak as well as the time we need
to spend maintaining these resources
and we would have never had the capacity
to have this many new components in our
solution all at once if we were supposed
to manage them all ourselves
and my reason for emphasizing that these
are the components that we're using at
the moment
is that we do have a
quite
high rate of change i would say
so we started developing this solution
before the norwegian data centers were
established
this means that we've had to adapt to
what which features would be offered in
norway and not
also taking into account the rapid
evolution of cloud technology we're
always prepared to swap out the
components or to upgrade the existing
ones that we have
and again terraform as i mentioned is a
great tool for doing exactly that
another important thing for us lately
has been cost management with regards to
these cloud components
because if you're not shy when selecting
a cost plan for these components the
bills could quickly add up
and so we've had to sit down and ask
ourselves questions like
do we need the trace log from our backup
function
and how long are we actually willing to
wait to find log data that's more than
30 days old
and by asking these questions we've been
able to
we've been able to sorry lost the threat
there let me just get back in
so asking these questions we've been
able to tweak our solution
in order to save costs without
compromising the functionality of our
solution
and so i'm going to go on to talk a bit
about some of the cloud components that
we're really happy with using
the first one of course is azure
kubernetes services
and so as you could see from our
infrastructure we do have quite
a number of kubernetes clusters
and again this is a great resource
because it's fully managed
this means that we have very few
responsibilities outside of deploying
our microservices and managing them
in addition azure kubernetes services
supports auto scaling
so this means that our applications are
able to scale both up and down depending
on the load that they're facing
once we've transferred all of the
application owners from altin 2 to alton
we're expecting to have several hundred
kubernetes clusters
and so microsoft's azure team might have
a bit more to do but we should be able
to manage just fine
we have azure cosmos db
so this is a document database that we
use to store metadata about the
applications and their instances
cosmos db is said to be highly available
and it's documented to have an
availability of
99.999 percent
pretty high
and if that wasn't enough it also
duplicates our data into multiple
locations automatically
as this database is hosted in azure you
could say that we have an unlimited
amount of storage should we need it
and at microsoft build
auto scaling for cosmos db was announced
and we're really exciting excited to
incorporate this
feature into our solution as well
finally we've saved the best for last
application insights
so you know when you have a bug and
you're not sure quite sure where the
root cause is where to start debugging
well application insights would be my
starting point 9 out of 10 times
so we use application insights to
monitor our services
so this goes for both the platform
components alton studio and also all the
apps of our application owners
app insights will draw out an
application map as you can see here
where we can see all of our micro
services and also the communication
lines between them
another feature that application
insights provides is that we can drill
down to a specific time frame
and see which requests are used most
often and also their average response
times
another great feature is drilling into a
single request
and this way we can see how the request
flows through all of our services
and these two features that i just
mentioned have been heavily used during
our load testing
we've been able to identify bottlenecks
and unnecessary or duplicate requests
as well
so i'm going to hand you guys over to
nina now and she's going to share a bit
about our experiences working on this
project
so we've been working on this project
now for
a little over two years um
and we are definitely some experiences
richer and we would like to share some
of those experiences with you guys
so
the first point that i would like to
make is that working on an open source
project has been really great
we have our backlog open on github on
the right side here you can see
a screenshot from just a few days ago
having our backlog open on github in
addition of course to our source code
means that we have gotten feedback
and wishes from the app developers and
government agencies that have been
following this project
at a very early stage
we've had app developers submit issues
and they can follow the progress of
those issues
to see
how they will be solved
now since we also only use open source
projects ourselves and we can do the
same
so we can modify
we can modify things to suit our needs
and we also have a great insight into
when new functionality will become
available in the tools and frameworks
that we use
now while having an open backlog on
github has been a really good thing
sort of plain github if as a tool for
managing the project and managing the
backlog has not worked that well for us
currently we are a quite small team
and that makes it manageable
but as you can see at the very top of
this screenshot from our
backlog
there are currently almost 600 open
issues and there have been a lot more
so actually managing this and
prioritizing and seeing
who is working on what has been quite
challenging especially previously when
we were a much larger team
uh we've had to test several different
plugins to work with github and we've
ended up with a plugin called zenhub
which we feel works quite well for us
finally a note on direction
and we would like to say that
shifting direction mid-project can
actually be a good
thing and now to elaborate a little bit
on that
when we started this project we focused
a lot around the alton studio solution
as a tool to build
apps
we focused so much on the tool and
possibly not enough on the actual apps
themselves
uh underways we decided to switch our
direction to focus more on
on the actual apps now this resulted in
us having to switch also from focusing
on users who do not know coding
towards users who actually do know how
to code and i'm sure you've seen this
reflected in what we've been explaining
today and probably
you would need to know at least a little
bit of coding
to properly customize your app
hopefully going forward we can
now continue building on the alton
studio solution now that our
apps are more mature
all right
i'll hand you over to iruna who will
tell you a little bit more about our
current status
yes so it's now
six thousand days since alton one went
in produce production it's
hundred days since art and two went into
production and there's over two years
since you started this minimum viable
products
so what is your status are we done yet
we went live on monday in fact
it's like
it's a great success for us that we are
able to go launch this platform uh this
monday
so
that's mean that the pilots are getting
ready to deploy their first applications
to their productions so we are helping
him out with the
initial apps
we have around 600 open issues as
mentioned
and we are still working from home but
it works fine
and further forward we're going to focus
on more stuff because as i mentioned we
have more than thousand digital services
on this old platform
and we want to move that to the new one
so we will focus on
building more flexibility on the forms
being able to build more advanced forms
components and so on
we will expand the types of process
tasks we can support
like payment and signing we will add and
many
more and
this is an event-driven architecture and
we need to define how we're going to
expose the events
so because we the goal for us is that we
want to have an event feed for every
citizen of norway every organization and
every agency and going to be exciting
tasks to build that solution
as mentioned many times we are open
source
our documentation is fully open source
data also
and on github you will find a link to
the
different documentation we have and we
will find a full detail about
the requirements both functional and
technical requirements
the principles we have
the different patterns we follow what
kind of capabilities both on the devops
capabilities and the runtime
capabilities of the platform
and on all the components and code
structure we are building so every
design details you find there go take a
look you can find details about all the
platform components
so and you will also find the
presentation you just had on there on a
couple of hours
and
with that i want to thank everyone for
joining
we're going to thank nc for letting us
come and present
and we are opening up for answering
questions
from schleck
yeah so i can see we have a few
questions on youtube so we'll start here
first
the first question is
are the development teams centered
around those microservices
so do we have an authorization team and
a pdf team and etc and
that it so are the different teams
available
let's see are they responsible for the
different services
and
i guess the answer now
no not yet we have been
we are currently not that big team and
we so we are covering more components
but there are special member teams that
focus on different components so
currently uh we the whole the team we
have one team sharing all components
and to speak of that team we're like six
five or six developers so it's not that
big a team i don't even think we have
enough team members to have a component
each
so another question here let's see
so you mentioned that you don't do
multi-tenant architecture is this due to
a government requirement
we of course investigate what the
government agency needs and so on and
some agencies would require that they
have an infrastructure that is separate
from others so and we want to support as
many agencies as possible and it's
based on history on current platform
that is not separated we have seen
instances of
poor code in one digital service
affecting others because of high load
and so on so it's a natural
experience and some requirement
yeah
and so another question from brian here
is since you're running multiple several
hundred
soon to be several hundred we're not
quite there yet but it's coming
so since we're running several
kubernetes clusters and application
insights and cosmos db
how are we hosting the costs do you want
to answer that nina i think
that has the best
answer for this
yeah so
currently this is a governmental
platform and it will be that so and how
the cost
is shared
is kind of a deal that is between the
agency and the norwegian digitalization
agency and
i think with the new architecture it is
more possible to split the cost if if
they want it to the different agencies
currently on current platform that's
impossible because we are using shared
resources and kind of saying that you
are using 10 and the euro seven it's not
possible
and we've used examples of application
owners with really large attachments for
instance should we share those costs or
should they be
be responsible for paying for storing
those attachments
and with their separate storage accounts
it's pretty easy to see yeah how much
they're using and what it costs
so another good question here let's see
tom had the same questions as brian so
let's hope we answer them we have
cybernetics 100 so despite all the good
work with the new alton platform
what are some top challenges that still
remain to be addressed in or by the new
platform
hmm
we're taking too long thank you
okay well uh one thing that i think was
barely mentioned at the end was this
idea of being able to
build the services without actually
having a lot of technical background
in the in the existing application or in
the existing platform we do
yes there are flaws but it is possible
to build a complete digital service
without actually having to know any code
i would say that if you're going to
build an app in the alton 3 solution
right now and you don't know anything
about coding it would have to be a very
very simple app
so so extending that and making it
easier
to actually build the apps
that's probably something
yeah we have seen during the we're open
time that
when making it user friendly it limits
the flexibility
and i don't believe that we really want
to go 100
usability what we talked about because i
think it's easier if we are learning
kids to code we can learn the agencies
to code also
very much yeah
let's see and so brian made a comment
here regarding the costs he's saying ah
oil money say no more
i guess that might be true we have
another question here from stefan
so could you say anything about the
advantages that you gain from hosting in
the cloud versus on-premise
do you want to take this one
yeah so
i was talking about application insights
right and i think so we're using that
only to react to instances or incidents
at the moment but using this as a
predictive tool as well i think would be
great and also for our agencies to get
more feedback on how their applications
are used and
when they're used to be able to collect
more data about the
citizens or the companies that they're
interacting with
i think another great thing would be to
run
larger analysis on the data sets that
they're collecting because that's pretty
easy now that it it's in the cloud
do you have any other advantage well i
think the last thing you mentioned that
because
having one common platform interior you
have enormous advantages doing big data
analysis of the data going through so
for a foreign agency if they want to
yeah and so a final question here we
have another one from brian
so azure devops azure api management
cosmos db
are we would we say that we're heavily
cloud locked or
if we were to decide to go to a
competing vendor or
go back to an on-premise solution
it's a good question and
one of the other principles i didn't
mention was to prevent that we are
locking ourselves in we have selected
like cosmos db but it's it's a document
databases and we could replace it with
something else
api management probably will be more
difficult but it we are not using so
much of the features in api management
it's just a gateway for api so we could
easily probably with some weeks of work
replace it with another software so it
has been an important
requirement for the norwegian
deteriorations that we're not locking in
on this on usher because
we are selecting azure now and it could
be something else in the future so
yeah it's important for us to
yeah we should get some more data
centers in norway than i would say
before we could consider them
i think that's about what we have of
time
thanks so much for watching us guys
reach out to us on twitter linkedin
wherever
and go see our code on github yeah link
is right here make a pull request please
thank you
b
i want to start this talk off with the
show of let's say virtual hands
so have you ever worked with a react
component that was just
particularly bad
have you ever written one
well
if you didn't at least mentally raise
your hand right now you're not just
lying to me you're lying to yourself
but what is this concept of a bad
component we had this intuition about
how it makes us feel but what
specifically made that component you
just thought of so bad
i've tried to come up with a few main
categories of
terribleness the first and most obvious
center is when the components api it's
props it's either too complex to
understand badly named or a combination
of both
if your api doesn't make sense it's
extra frustrating when there's no
documentation to explain it to you
or even worse if there is some but it's
out of date
if you've been so unfortunate that
you've had to fix a bug on one of these
bad components you're probably turned
pale by looking at how it's tested
if it's tested at all
complex components make for complex
testing which in turn leads you to
silently skip that part
and if you're adding a feature or
rewriting your components to use hooks
you're probably in for a treat
hundreds or thousands of lines of code
jump at you that you have to change
and making sure it's impossible to do a
single
character change without breaking at
least 20 tests and definitely dropping
ie support
what you're left with then is a pretty
poor user experience not the end user
they might not notice a thing react is
cool like that
but the user that matters in this
context is you the developer
it's important to feel compassion for
your fellow developers and write code
that they will find easy to work with so
how can we turn this frown
upside down
we're going to explore what makes good
components good and how you can write
react code that your colleagues will
love code that you will love in a few
weeks time
oh by the way uh before we get into this
i'm christopher and i work for beck here
in oslo norway
i've been writing react apps for most of
my career and i can tell you right away
that all of the tips that you'll receive
in this talk is earned the hard way my
colleagues will probably tell you that
i've learned them
through repeated failure
first though i want to dive into this
term compassion
it's one of those words i struggle to
define
to me it's that feeling you get when
thinking of how others feel
the most formal definition is
co-suffering or feeling for another but
no matter how you word it
it's about putting yourself in somebody
else's shoes and envisioning their
struggles
showing an interest in other people's
well-being is part of most if not all
cultures and religions
understanding how people's struggles and
hardships can be a powerful emotion
and a catalyst for change
most people have probably felt some sort
of compassion for the situation
currently unfolding in the us
we try to understand how african
americans feel when they are being
systematically targeted harassed and
abused
some help out by donating spreading the
message of equality or protesting for
their cause but all this is driven by
the compassion for people in a hard
situation
but
how does this all translate how do we
apply this very very emotion driven
concept of compassion
to react
well
my claim is that code is communication
when you write code you're transmitting
your intent to other people or your
future yourself
the people reading your code want to
understand you but for optimizing this
communication flow
uh it's it's something that we really do
explicitly
again leading to intent being lost in
the translation
the common
componentization of front-end code
is making collaboration easier than ever
you can create custom hooks and complete
ui pieces and ship them off as an npm
package in minutes
that also puts an added importance on
this developer to developer
communication how do you onboard users
to your open source library for example
how do you make them feel it's a good
library to use
the way we communicate is different from
our day-to-day communication too because
instead of words and body language like
we are doing now
now we communicate through props and
docs and test cases
writing code that other people will love
to use
work with and extend is hard but it's
what i call compassionate and creating
components that takes other people's
needs and wants into consideration
that's what i call compassionate
components
so
but so how do we get there how do we
show compassion to our fellow developers
uh through our react code
well first we need to figure out what
makes good components good and in many
cases
cases it's the opposite of what makes
them bad
so
first you want to create explicit and
extendable props that are both intuitive
and easy to use
you want to write extensive
documentation that is easily accessible
when you need it and use tools and write
tests that give you real confidence in
your code it doesn't get in the way of
writing or refactoring it
write code that is easy to extend with
new features as well while still
maintaining all the other traits of a
good component and those are the topics
we'll discuss in this talk
props
back in the 90s props were some people
gave you when they looked particularly
fly
today we use the term to indicate that
data and functions we sent to our react
components
perhaps not as fly
but i digress
these props is the interface of our
component this is how we interact with
it or put in another way it's the api of
our component
we pass data in and we
expect a result to show up in our
browser or mobile app
so how do we create a nice api for our
components are there any rules or prior
art we're going to lean on here or do we
have to figure out what's important from
scratch
now api design is not a new term
we've all probably heard it before
it's probably decades old but we
typically think of api design in
connection to rest and soap apis or some
other data transferring stuff
but as it turns out api design can be
just as much about how you structure
your interfaces between your components
when i did the research for this talk i
read some prior art on what people would
consider good api traits and we found a
few things that most people agreed on
first of all is versioning because
stability is key
the more churn you have in your apis the
more pissed off your users will be
because their intuition is broken and
they need to learn the new api and
unlearn the old one
make sure you have as few breaking
changes in your apis as possible and
keep each one as small as possible
error messages they're
incredibly important
because when there's an error good
information is key to fix it so help
users fix the problem instead of blaming
them for doing something wrong
developers are flimsy beings and they
don't like surprises so make your api
intuitive by following the best
practices and
naming conventions that apply to you
and most importantly do things the same
way across all of your apis
and finally minimize your api surface
the less surface your api has
the less the user has to learn
expose only what you know that your
users will need
and only when they need it
now these are good guidelines for rest
apis but it sure seems like they would
translate well for react components as
well right
so based on this insight and about six
years of experience here are my favorite
techniques when designing the props of
my components
first i like to avoid boolean props if
at all possible a boolean is absolute in
its very nature and it doesn't lend
itself to making extendable interfaces
let me explain with an example
when you when you're creating your new
fancy button you might want to create
different variants of it let's say you
have a base version without any styling
at all and a primary button that
you use for the really important stuff
like signing people in
since jsx has this really nice syntax
for boolean props where you can skip
using the value
you'll just write a primary prop which
turns your button bright and attention
seeking in no time at all
a few weeks later you're creating a new
landing page and those attention seeking
primary buttons needs a toned down
sibling
so you add a secondary prop which
magically makes all your buttons a bit
more laid back still we're all good
at some point though you're asked to add
the cta variant by the sales team since
cta or call to action but needs to blink
or whatever they do to make sure people
buy your stuff
and this starts to complicate things
because you're now pulling in a new
naming category or strategy could a
button be both primary and a cta
you don't know but you now have primary
buttons and secondary buttons and cta
buttons but technically you can have all
three simultaneously
there's nothing that stops you from
doing this at least not technically and
even if you know that the cta button and
primary button are two props that are
mutually exclusive the next developer to
join your team might not
instead i suggest you use enumerated
values in a string like bryant here
later if you want to add new variants
you don't have to expand the api with a
new prop
just a new available enum value for the
already existing one
this make sure you don't allow for
impossible states too so it's a double
win
that being said
sometimes boolean props are the right
tool for the job sometimes things are
just true or false
and the concepts they describe isn't an
expandable one
whether the button is disabled or
whether it's in a loading state or not
those could still be valid use cases
just
think twice before you decide on using a
boolean prop because more often than not
you should be using enumerated values
instead
one of my favorite things
about react is that what makes it easy
to compose huge apps from tiny building
blocks or components
each with its own responsibility ui and
interface
you should take advantage of this part
of react make components that could pose
together
i'll explain with an example
let's look at a modal component now i
know a lot of people aren't huge fans of
this particular piece of ui but i've
encountered it enough times that i know
it might be relatable
they often end up requiring tons of
props though since there are so many
variations we need to cater to
now
this is just a tiny fraction of what
you'll see in
complete modal libraries and the list
goes on and on
to me understanding and learning this
huge api is a really hard task and i'd
rather just not
it's not a very compassionate thing to
ask your consumers to deal with in my
opinion
instead we can break things up into a
modal's unique parts
and it has a few of them the overlay the
faded out background
the white content box on top of it the
close button
perhaps a title
a content
holder and perhaps even a footer with
some action buttons on it
and by creating small components that
combine together to create something you
have the flexibility to create exactly
what you want
if you want something out of the
ordinary
perhaps we wanted a version without a
close button or perhaps we don't have a
meaningful title
or perhaps we wanted a pink overlay
today
the downside of this
is of course that this flexibility is a
huge overkill like most of the time
most people use complex components in
the exact same way
giving them this huge api is just going
to be in the way or create a ton of tiny
design variations which we don't really
want either
but what's stopping us from having both
luckily there's nothing stopping us from
creating another component that just
does all this boilerplate for us and
combining all of these compostable
components in a predefined way
these components can cater to the 90 to
95 percent of use cases where we want
the default layout or default behavior
and if you want something special you
can always break it down to the more
basic pieces and roll your own
this is a great technique for a lot of
different components from buttons and
drop downs to product presentations and
site layouts
my third rule of thumb when it comes to
components and their apis is to make
sure i allow for semantics
when it comes to creating reusable
components you'll never have a guarantee
or the full picture for what context
they'll be put into
we could use divs to create all of our
elements i guess but by doing that we'll
lose all the semantic structure
structuring possibilities we get by
using html
to its full potential
so how can we allow for semantics
take this card component it's a box that
might have an image and definitely some
content
there's no real semantics to a card
at least a generic one like this but the
way it's used might vary here we might
assume it's a div
but it could also be a part of a list
and be a list item if bunched together
with a lot of other cards
we could of course create two very
similar components like a debit card or
base card and list item card
but that leads to a lot of code
duplication and potential future bugs
so
luckily there's another way
by providing an ass prop
we can allow the developer to decide the
correct element based on the context
it's in
this can be even more powerful too you
can send in other components that render
your component
think of your favorite routing libraries
link component like react routers link
we can make our card into a link card
and a few characters of code
but how can we implement this
here is a super basic implementation of
a card component it renders a div with a
card class on it and that's about it so
let's introduce that new as prop
here we rename the as prop to element
with a capital e this is done so that we
can override what dom element is
rendered by our component
note that if we don't pass in an as prop
we'll default to a dip
we can also do this
by deconstructing the props directly in
the argument list complete with renaming
and providing a default value now i know
the syntax is
trash but it's
one of those things you get comfortable
with
really quick for some reason
now our component is completely
adaptable to whatever context you put it
in and you can do the same with all
kinds of elements
cards can become whatever you want some
buttons might need to be links instead
your grid system might provide some
extra content hints by
using sections or articles for in the
right places
and you can create truly basic
components that can be composed together
with all the semantic meaning you need
you might have noticed though that my
last example was somewhat flawed
i made my card into a link and provided
it with a two prop to indicate where it
should link to but that prop was never
applied anywhere it just was forgotten
about so that wouldn't work
and think about more generic components
like buttons or input fields do you even
know half the available html attributes
for an input field
i don't and
i don't have to thanks my next tip
spread the remaining props
since we're
talking about our previous example let's
go back and fix it we first collect all
the remaining props from our
destructuring assignment and use the
rest operator to place them in an object
we call
rest next we spread those props on our
root element with the spread operator
like so
there's one more thing to do though
because if you paid attention here as
well you might have noticed that i
introduced a new bug right now
if the developer passes the class name
it will override the existing card class
that's probably not what i want i wanted
to
extend my component not just override
stuff
so to fix this i pick out the class name
prop from the props object so that it's
not in the rest object i end up
spreading out
i give it a default value of an empty
string and then i concatenate it
together with the existing class prop
and there you have it
now we can pass in whatever props you
want without getting into trouble the
technique
works really well the with the spreading
of props but it comes with a few caveats
though
first you always need to remember to
combine any internal props you're adding
to your component so if you add an
internal on click handler make sure you
allow the user to send in its own
onclick handler as well and then you
need to remember to call both of them
second if you can't combine props you
have to decide whether people should be
able to override your props or if you
should override theirs
and
that kind of depends on the use case and
mostly personal preference to be honest
with you i like to let the end user to
decide as much as possible but that's
always up to you and the situation
and third
this works best for components with the
single dom node so it's easy to
understand where the props will be
placed there are some exceptions of
course but complex components often lead
to misunderstandings and hard to
understand apis
but with these caveats in mind though
you should remember to spread the
remaining props wherever you can
whenever you're designing a component
it's easy to get creative with the props
naming those html attributes from 1990s
are so hard to type and they often could
have had better names i guess but i urge
you
avoid renaming existing dom attributes
in your props
i'll show you why through an example
at a previous project we created the
almighty button component it was
flexible and nice looking lots of people
used it throughout the organization
there was a few different types of
buttons though like a primary and a
secondary button and we used the type
prop to specify what type or
button it was
and this worked
out well too up until one developer
placed a few buttons next to each other
inside of a form it turns out there is a
native type prop or type attribute on
the button element which takes a value
of either submit button or reset
and the default is submit so when a
button has a type of submit it triggers
the forms on submit function and we
didn't want that to happen in our
particular use case we wanted nothing to
happen except the onclick
command since we spread the props though
we didn't have a way to set both that we
wanted the button to be primary and to
be a regular button button
there were tons of people using our
button throughout the organization and
since we didn't want to create a huge
break and change for people we did a
huge mistake and introduced the button
type prop
now this solved our problem at hand but
it created a terrible api and even if
you knew the backstory to it uh this
like it made sense but new developers
that joined the organization understood
nothing they thought we were terrible
developers
which in hindsight i guess we were
so learn from our mistakes back then and
never override an existing dom attribute
with a prop name
even if it's esoteric and you probably
won't even care about it but just come
up with another name instead
like this api for example which is much
easier to understand and this goes on
for
tons of other types of props too i see
for example renaming dom props a lot
when it comes to area attributes
like instead of just writing out area
busy like normal person would you might
write is
loading or
area busy in camel case
and this leads to a lot of variations
across your code base probably because
different people come up with different
naming strategies so it could be loading
is loading lusted in norwegian or
it could be a ton of different stuff
and all that makes it hard to
intuitively guess the api of your
component and other components in your
score of components so instead
take advantage of the fact that you're
spreading your props already this way
you don't have to come up with names
first of all and you don't have to write
a prop type or typing for it you don't
have to add a new prop for every new
area or dom attribute that you or your
consumers can think of that's a bonus
this provides you with a small yet
well-defined api that is flexible enough
to rarely change it all
these five rules of thumb will help you
create components that are easy to
understand easy to use and easy to
extend and even easier to like but the
most important takeaway from this
section is that you should sign your api
and don't let it be a coincidence
design the props of your component so
that they're easy for the next developer
to understand and extend if they need to
the next thing i want to talk about is
documentation and
documentation is a loaded word i know
it's filled with the memories of the
stuff you wrote into confluence once and
nobody ever saw again
and most of us are probably
filled with bad experiences with
documentation too because it's tedious
to write nobody ever reads it and if
somebody does stumble across it you know
it's outdated
but have you ever experienced amazing
docs
when done right documentation can be a
joy both to write and to consume
great documentation is always easily
available and available right when you
need it where you need it
great docs are always up to date even
with that latest feature that you just
shipped
and lastly great documentation makes it
easier for other developers or even
other well future you to understand how
your code works
which in turn turn speeds up development
time and cuts down on cursing
so let's look at some ways we can make
our code more readable and
understandable through documentation
the most important part of documentation
to me is
that the documentation shows up whenever
i need it
whenever i hover a component or like
type it in and auto complete it i want
the editor to tell me all i need to know
turns out doing this today is pretty
simple
js doc is a way of writing comments that
is easily parsable by our editor which
will show whenever you hover a component
or a prop or a custom book or a function
or whatever really
and here is what it looks like
you started block comment with two stars
instead of one and you're in js doc mode
here i've added some docs to our card
component from earlier you can write
long paragraphs if you want but a simple
explanation of the what the how and the
why usually suffices
you can even add examples
these will show up and can be great
it can be great to show both simple and
more advanced usages of your components
and in vs code at least you even get
syntax highlighting
you can also document your props
complete with deprecation warnings and
aliases and each of these prop comments
will show up whenever i autocomplete any
other props on that component
that is incredibly useful
not only does it show up just in time so
i can learn just in time but since it's
co-located with your code it should
never get out of date and it also
documents your code for future
maintainers
there is a lot of features in js doc and
i recommend you give it a shot here's a
great resource i used to remember what
the different keywords mean but it also
auto-completes in your editor
and don't
worry about writing this down i'll post
the slides after
sometimes you'll want a documentation
website for devs to visit
you see this a lot with component
libraries or design systems i made a few
you want a bit more pros about what to
do and what to avoid and you definitely
want some nice interactive examples to
play with
there's a few tools you can use to
create stuff like that today but my
favorite is by far the gatsby-based dial
tool docs
docs is a single dependency and gives
you basically all you need out of the
box it gives you a live playground
editor hot reloading for development it
parses your props and documents them for
you and it gives you a themeable and
plugable design that you can
customize to
whatever degree you want
it works by scanning your repository or
folders for jsx enabled markdown files
and creating a statically generated
website you can host wherever
that means you can co-locate your
markdown documentation with your code as
well
another added bonus is that it parses
your dot comments and shows your inline
code comments in an easy to read format
on the web
this is a huge bonus because it means
that you in order to be both on the web
and be documented in the code
you need no documentation duplication
whatsoever
this is how it looks by default by the
way you even
it even ships with the dark mode if you
want that it's a great way to create
more in-depth documentation too which
can come in handy for some of the more
advanced components you put together
another way of documenting your code is
creating really good error messages and
warnings that show up in the console
while developing
this comes with a few upsides
first of all it helps people new to your
code base to use your code correctly
so if they consume a context without
wrapping your app in the correct
provider
or if they pass in an illegal
combination of props or if they're using
a deprecated feature they can be told
why
stuff doesn't work in full sentences
perhaps you can even link to a custom
page in your docs documentation website
that goes into more detail about what
one should do and how you
[Music]
solve deprecations for example
the second nice thing about dev only
warnings is that they live with your
code
they are code i guess so code doesn't
get outdated the way documentation does
it gets removed or refactored away so
thus the warnings are never out of date
people reading the code can understand
why something goes wrong
which is also a huge plus
finally if we're worried about the bytes
here
you can three shake all of these
warnings out when you're building for
production that means zero added bytes
to your app yet a much better user
experience for the developers
documentation is key
and it doesn't have to be boring it
doesn't have to be outdated and it
doesn't have to be left
unread focus on placing most of your
documentation inside of your component
files
next to your code use jsdoc to integrate
it with your editor use js or use docs
to create interactive documentation
websites use dev only warnings to
document edge cases deprecations and
misuse
and remember to link to relevant
documentation
sites in your dev only warnings as well
the end result is that your colleagues
will love reading your code you put
their need for information first while
providing it to them just in time
so
we've learned some ways to create
well-crafted props for our components
and looked at how we can document their
usage
the last part of the puzzle to create
truly compassionate components at least
me
is to build trust
we need to trust our components
but what does it mean to trust your
components in my eyes you need to be
confident that the components
works as intended and that means no bugs
edge cases covered
it's both usable it's accessible
and i can test the component and all its
test cases manually but i'd rather have
software do it
also you need to have a strong sense of
confidence if you're ever to refactor
your code
again you could solve this by full
regression tests all the time but those
are in this are they're expensive and
impractical
so we need to be confident that we've
done a good job implementing stuff
before we ship it to our users
but what's the best way to get there
uh writing tests for front-end code
used to be a nightmare there was shared
state a lot of times between the tests
the feedback loop was always really
really long and we wrote an amazing
amount of unit tests
today the situation is pretty different
we have tools that help us write better
code
the test runners have become much more
developer friendly
and but we still tend to test
implementation details through a lot of
these unit tests
in this last section we'll look at how
you can build trusts in your components
while not getting in the way of a good
developer experience
there are lots of problems that we can
use existing tooling to find and report
for us
i mean us as developers we're obviously
pretty smart
but machines can be pretty clever too if
a program can analyze our code and find
bugs for us we can do more useful stuff
with our time
the most popular tool for analyzing our
code these days is eslint
and a linter like eslint
can spot pretty advanced bugs and fix
them sometimes
you can find potentially infinite loops
or you can find like a missing
dependency in your use effect
or a missing area label and your icon
buttons for example or just code smells
in general
there are tons of ways to set up eslint
but the defaults that ship would create
react app is usually more than enough if
you're not using create react app for
your app you can use its predefined
rules
with extending their config in your
eslint config and then just add or
remove whatever you don't like
eslint has saved me from so
shipping so many errors and it helps you
avoid
avoiding testing the kind of bugs that
they fix
there's another type of static analysis
which is particularly helpful when
creating react applications and that's
static type systems
as you probably know javascript is a
dynamic language with no built-in type
system
this provides us with a lot of
flexibility when it comes to solving
challenges
but it also doesn't provide any safety
net at all
that worked back in the days when you
only had to do a few minor things in
javascript but in today's application
world that's kind of not good enough
the result is that we have to ensure our
code can handle whatever input we throw
at it leading to the need for lots and
lots of unit tests which in turn
sucks
instead we can use type systems like
typescript or flow or more likely
typescript to type our interfaces
here's an example of the props passed to
our button component earlier we can
specify the type of arguments and check
that the code calling our components are
doing it correctly
compile time and this way there's no way
to misuse the api and get a really nice
and tight feedback loop
and a little
side note uh typescript or flow used to
be a really hard word react but in
modern react with the custom hooks and
stuff like that
it's really
as easy as you can think of think of i i
was super afraid of it and it turned out
to be really really nice
so if you haven't given it a shot give
it a shot
there's actually tons of potential
upsides to use uh type in using a type
system like typescript in your code
right now i won't go through them all in
detail it's a an hour-long talk in
itself
but my favorite ones are that it's much
easier to discover what's available in
api it gets you get this
great auto discovery and auto completion
it also replaces most of your unit tests
with actual code
and finally it makes refactoring so much
easier because you can programmatically
refactor stuff without having to
remember all the stuff that you need to
change the name of
so consider introducing types to your
code base you can do it gradually if you
want and there are tons of great
resources out there to get you started
another thing i want you to remember
about testing your react components is
that you should avoid testing
implementation details
and test the stuff like your users use
your component
by doing this you'll have much more
sturdy unit tests which won't break
whenever you do a refactor and you'll
test that stuff will work for your
actual users and not just in your test
suit
but how do you do that well first off i
suggest you throw away whatever you're
using today and start using react
testing library it's made by the testing
wizard uh of us can see dodds
and it helps you interact with your code
like your users do
next you should test your components
only through their props by that i mean
never manipulate internal state
or call instance methods on class
components instead just re-render your
app with different props and verify that
the right things are rendered
finally you should assert that your
components work by asserting on visible
output
rather than class names or ids
react testing library has a ton of great
selectors to do this for you and as a
bonus you can actually use accessible
selectors to improve the accessibility
of your code as well
through getting stuff by role to
remember that you have to have different
area roles for example
finally
i want to suggest that you try to
write broad tests that covers most of
your components
if you're testing on an app level
aim for writing integration tests that
tests the complete vertices of your app
by doing this you can write much less
tests a few tests will cover huge parts
of your code
and provide important documentation of
happy cases edge cases and error-ness
cases
so these are some of my best tips when
it comes
to making both yourself future
developers and consumers trust your
components
and trust is important when you're
building code other people will use
without it we second guess every
decision made even if they were made for
a particular reason
to me
code is communication
code is the language we speak with our
fellow developers and the way we
communicate our intent
so if you don't remember to communicate
in a compassionate way considering the
needs of the recipient
we'll end up writing code that's hard to
understand tricky to extend and often
end up being replaced in the long run
instead i suggest that you'll consider
some of the tips in this talk to improve
that communication
first of all you need to put some
thought into how you structure the props
over your components
this will make
this will help make your components
intuitive to use while making them easy
to extend
creating a good set of props doesn't
even need to be that hard if you just
follow a few simple guidelines in some
talk
you need to create documentation that
shows up when you need it this will make
your components much more usable by the
end user
in addition it will help future
maintainers and that includes you to
understand your code better
use static analysis for what it's worth
you can do a lot less testing by just
adding a linter and a type system
and a lot less writing at that
providing a type system is a
particularly helpful of a way of
avoiding bugs while improving api
discoverability as well
and when you test make sure to write
wide reaching tests that use your code
like your users do
this provides you with a lot of
confidence when you refactor or
otherwise change your code in some way
in addition you don't have to do a lot
of manual testing before you go into
production
and finally
take a big step back
try to envision other developers using
your code because when you empathize
with their needs and wants you're
showing them compassion and when you
make sure you're
you code for other people those other
people will end up loving your code
that is my
talk
thanks to tom for watching i'll be in
the slack channel answering all your
questions if you have any
what you're listening to right now
is the iliac suite for string quartet
and this was the first ever piece of
music to be written by a computer
and it was written by this computer
this doesn't look like a computer you
usually see because this is a mechanical
computer
and larry john hiller used this computer
to compose the piece of music that we
just heard
this was something he started in the mid
50s and it took him a few good years to
complete
so ladies and gentlemen
welcome
at this time at the ndc is where
everyone would be starting to look
forward to the legendary ndc party
unfortunately this year we won't have an
ndc party and there won't be any dill
betty-led ndc band to play your music
but i'm here
and i'm going to take you along on the
journey through the history of computer
played music and by that i mean music
that was played by computers
so my name is anders norris and i'm
going to take you on a journey so
welcome along
and this is a journey that starts in one
of the countries where ndc has one of
their conferences
and no it's not america this is a story
that starts in australia what you're
seeing right now is the ciceroc computer
and the cisrec computer was one of the
few computers around in the world after
the second world war when people
realized that computers were a smart
thing to have
now this computer didn't have that
regular user interface that you're used
to
but it had a small speaker connected to
it so that the engineers operating the
computer could hear a small little beep
beep
whenever the computer was finished
processing something or running a
program
now one of the engineers working with
this realized that he can modulate the
signal going to this little speaker
and using that
he managed to play program the first
ever piece of music to be played by a
computer
[Music]
so this is colonel boogie's march and
it's marching band music now this kind
of music was really popular at the turn
of the 19th century
all over the world actually not only in
germany
and this was one of the songs that he
chose to program so this piece of
marching band music was the first ever
to be played by computers
and as i said this didn't start in
america but americans were far behind
and whenever things were happening at in
america at this time it was happening at
bell laboratories
so in 1957
a engineer at bell laboratories was
working on the ibm
704 mainframe computer and what it was
working on was
making that computer
able
to make sounds which is kind of
a obvious thing to do when you're a
telephone company
now
he was working together with newman
gutman and together they created the
first ever dsl or at least the first
ever computer-based dsl for creating
music because if you think about it
whenever we speak about domain-specific
languages or what's known as dsls we
always come back to referencing sheet
music because if you know how to read
sheet music you can play just about
everything and one of the things you
could play if you knew how to read sheet
music or the music one programming
language is this little piece of music
called silver scales
[Music]
so silver scales
was actually the first ever piece of
music to be released on a vinyl album
and what you're seeing right now is that
very wine album it's called music for
mathematics and it was released by deca
a few
years after max matthews programmed this
piece of music and this was a sort of
music concrete and that takes us to
putney
he keeps it in his garden shed and it's
called digital pdp eight oblique s yes
it's a computer and it has a hobby too
composing music
peter helps with the ideas for the
actual performance is all digital's
worth
so
the brit peterson ave having quite a bit
of kit in his garden shed
started experimenting with electronic
music in the mid 60s and he had these
two
digital pdp
slash eight 12-bit micro computers
and for that he created his own
programming language that was based on
the digital pdp macro assembler
and he called that muses and you see the
code for it right now it's not music as
you're used to but this resembles
something related to music you play a
note with note command and then you have
a duration and you have a pitch and so
forth for the note and this he combined
together in small little pieces of code
that performed music and this was
as experimental as the code you're
seeing right now and he took this with
him to the queen elizabeth hall
for a performance
of this kind of music
the next item particular unattended
computer by peter navief is a true live
performance in the sense that no
magnetic tape is being used at all
furthermore the computer has a choice at
various stages in the procedure and the
piece therefore comes out different
every time it's played the performance
you're about here is therefore unique
and unrepeatable
first of all checks are made to see that
the composition is correctly loaded into
the computer
the computer is started and will carry
out the performance unattended
so a nice piece of proto-techno music
going on right here and this was
recorded in the queen elizabeth hall
in january 1968 in london and the queen
elizabeth hall is just whereby ndc
london first was hosted so this is a bit
of ndc history as well going on here now
peter synovia's piece uh party of her
unattended computer was special in that
no tape was being used as i said in this
presentation of the work and this
computer was actually playing that piece
of music live on stage and that was the
first time that ever happened so this
was a landmark event
and the press weren't that impressed by
this the times wrote technically it may
be a triumph of skill and knowledge but
what we heard resemble the dreariest
kind of neo weapon drawn out to
inordinate length
now for the less cultured among you out
there
neo weapon which
is in relation to the austrian composer
anton von weben who create a tonal music
but even if the mainstream media weren't
really impressed by this
the
specific journals writing about
computers such as wireless world and
computer
weekly
were
enraged about this and they wrote
pages up on pages about this performance
so this is a landmark event in computer
music history
but
we have to go back to the bell
laboratories to really see the big
landmark events of the 1960s
and
we're back with the ibm
9704 computer
and
way back before petersenov did his thing
in 1961 programmers at
bell laboratories were experimenting
with making computers talk
in the voice recognizable by humans
and these two people here
john kelly and carol lochbaum did
something amazing but it's mostly thanks
to carol in front here sitting there
programming the ibm 704 computer because
she painstakingly programmed in
the song a bicycle bait built for two
every single wow
and it sounded like this
[Music]
i am
the beautiful piece of music a bicycle
built for two
and of course the
the music here was programmed by none
other than max matthews which we've met
a bit earlier now some of you
might have recognized this music as
something you have heard before and this
is the reason why
yes
i'd like to hear that
take it for me
it's called
daisy
give me your answer
so one of the most
iconic
death scenes in one of the most iconic
films with one of the most iconic
computers and all of film history
has a reference to this piece of music
where you first ever heard a computer
sing
now if 2001 wasn't a beautiful film
already it's now going to be forever and
ever
and this film is from 1969 the final
year of the 60s and that brings us
over to the heyday of the 1970s and
where computer music started to take off
for real
now this is a classic game this is space
invaders and you might not think of the
soundtrack in space in waiters as music
but if you listen you have those four
bass notes going down and down and down
that's a piece of music and space
invaders was the first ever game to
feature music
used in a way to elicit a response from
the player because as the aliens
approach and get closer and closer to
your little spaceship the music is going
to go faster and faster and become more
and more intense causing you to
lose some of your concentration and
finally
kill yourself so that you have to put in
another quarter and play it all over
again so this little simple piece of
music is an example of how music was
used in video games and has been used
forever and ever after
to
elicit a response from you as a player
just a few years later though music and
video games were something totally
different and this is the
the game rally x
and this featured
music by kasu kuzuru
and he wrote down every single note for
the programmer to
paint certainly programming hexadecimal
machine language code into the game
but it resulted in a kind of funky
soundtrack and you have that sound that
is going to be genre defining for what
is going to be known as chip music later
and incidentally we
recently saw the first piece of music to
be released on vinyl being computer
music this is the first ever video game
soundtrack to be released
[Music]
on a vinyl soundtrack and as well and
that happened six years after the game
came out in 1984 on japanese imprint yen
records
[Music]
but you didn't only have one records to
take computer music into your home you
also had this the iconic atari 2600 and
this game is called the music machine
why not it's a talk about computer music
now this is a rather rare game it was
only sold in christian bookstores but it
has that little soundtrack at the
beginning and it's amazing that they
were able to create this kind of music
with this simple machine because this
had a 5-bit pitch that means that it had
32 different tones it could play tones
not notes and the frequencies were sort
of influenced by the synchronization
signal of the television it was
connected to so everything was a bit out
of tune
and it had limited sort of weight force
it could create so even if this sounded
really simple it's really amazing that
when we're able to create this kind of
music but obviously people deserve
something better
[Music]
lets you play hundreds more games than
any video machine plus draw program even
do music
[Music]
yes the legendary commodore 64 with the
legendary most technologies
6581 sound processor in this
and the designer of this ship robert
janz said that he thought the sound
chips on the market including those in
atari computers were primitive and
obviously had beside been designed by
people who knew nothing about music
and he wanted to change that with the
design of this now this one was
originally designed to have 32 channels
now it only ended up having three in the
commodore 64 but it's still designed for
those 32 channels and what you can do if
you have a few commodore 64's laying
around you can actually open them up
take out these processors and stack them
on top to get more channels than it
originally had so this is a
legendary piece of
musical hardware and it gave us
sounds like this and just listen to this
this is mule by electronic arts from
1983 one of the first games to be
released for the commodore 64. now the
soundtrack here is entirely different
from what the atari 2600 had brought
but this is actually quite simple
compared to what happened a few years
later with legendary soundtracks like
this one commando from 1985 by rob
hubbard and just look at the
oscilloscopes here there is so much
going on and that is why because rob
hubbard and other musicians using the
commodore 64 realized that you could
play around with the different
soundtrack channels on the commodore 64
and tweak the sounds and for any of you
who have ever touched a real live
synthesizer you know that the magic
happens when you twist the knobs around
to get that fat funky fresh sound out of
it so this one is amazing
so why does
nintendo from the same year sound like
this
due respect to kochi condo but distance
doesn't sound nearly as funky as the
commodore 64 music and the reason is
this if you look at the oscilloscopes
here nintendo had made some choices for
their musicians that it would have two
square waves one triangle wave and one
noise wave and this was all you had and
this the reason for this
is why all nintendo games sound mostly
the same you also had a sample channel
that you could use but the nintendo
cartridges didn't really have space to
have samples so that mostly were was
left unused so the commodore 64
was the master at the time
so much that in 1999 the swedish synth
producer electron
bought up the entire surplus stock
of sid
sound chips and created this little
beauty called the sid station
and this is a synthesizer that gives you
the original classic sound of the
commodore 64. and if you've heard music
by daft punk or the swedish pop star
robin or norwegian electronic pioneers
rakes up you've heard this
because this is the flip side to rake
subs first ever seven inch single
and this is where they pay homage
to their origins and where they came
from this is made with the sounds of the
commodore 64. and this is the beautiful
very rare and unknown race up song the
64 position
but it has that sound
and it has that funky sound chip groove
that we know to know as ship music
these days so those guys in red shop
knew where they were coming from
and the commodore 64 opened up the
possibility for people to use their
computer to make music in an entirely
different way
now this gentleman on the photo here is
chris hillsbeck
aged 17 in 1985
and that year he won a competition in a
german computer magazine
where
he created this piece of music called
shapes the year after he created this
piece of software called the sound
monitor which was a domain specific
language for writing music for the
commodore sid chip now this took a step
away from the music software that had
been available before that
allowed you to use classical musical
notation to create your music and
instead you wrote your music with
hexadecimal codes and so forth using the
language of the computer instead of the
language of music
and chris hillsback started a trend with
this that was carried further with this
young gentleman this is johan hipple a
few years later working on the atari st
computer
and
i got fooled by atari's marketing to get
myself an atari st because it had
this yamaha sound processor in it and
yamaha is my favorite combined
motorcycle and synthesizer producer
so i got this one it turns out that this
chip was an
off-the-shelf
generic sound processor just produced on
licensed by yamaha and it was rather
primitive compared to the commodore 64.
but johan hipple inspired by the music
created on the commodore 64 pushed this
to the limits and created this sort of
music but carrying forward the music of
of
chris halflick and the other pioneers on
the commodore 64. but where the action
was really at these days
was on this computer and it's of course
the classic commodore amiga
now we've all heard the stories about
how steve jobs allowed his engineers to
sign the inside of the macintosh
computer case now jay miner the manager
at commodore
he was way ahead of steve jobs he
allowed his engineers to name
their ships after their second others
and this here is the poor music
processor in the in the commodore amiga
and just listen to this piece of music
by danish
composer jasper kid
it's entirely different from what we had
on the other computer and this is the
fast tracker computer software that
built on the sound tracker concept that
carson blasky introduced in
1987 and has been used
in
many different ways to change music
production ever since
but before
we leave the amiga entirely we have to
see
where the geniuses of chris hospice and
jochen hippo meets because this is the
classic game kirk turrican 2 and if you
listen real closely
there is a really rich full soundtrack
here
and that is because this one has
seven voices and that's more than the
four voices that commodore amigo
actually had because this is where the
teenage engineering geniuses of these
two guys meet where chris hillsback uses
the algorithms that johan hippo came up
with for the atari st
to be able to
mix as many soundtracks as they want
together and really use the computer as
a composing device
and these are a few
12 inches from my own collection and i'm
going to let someone else tell you this
story about norwegian musician eric
because his story is worth telling you
would be correct to call those record
seminal that he made because
listen to them
[Music]
people should be aware of the equipment
he used to make those records
people would laugh now your phone is
more powerful
[Music]
the stuff he did
freed a lot of
producers from what they believed was
right and wrong
producers like him
is really necessary for for music to
grow
yes battle star xb7 by erot and this
musician
created music on his pc using fast
tracker software and he changed the
norwegian new disco scene forever so if
it hadn't been for eret we wouldn't have
the entire wave of norwegian musicians
and he created this with minimal
equipment in his bedroom thank you
but minimal equipment could actually
also produce proper pop music and this
is calvin harris from his debut album
from 2007
and he didn't have much gear at that
time either because he hadn't become a
famous producer yet so he created the
entire album using a amiga 1200 computer
and tracker software so this is
legendary software so legendary that
polliand producer of boutique synths
actually released this little beauty
earlier this year and this is a hardware
sound tracker so this is taking the
software project that carson oblovsky
started back in the 1980s
and putting it back into a hardware
package you can use for performance on
stage it's beautiful but people have
been using other kinds of hardware to
create music
in all sorts of strange ways
now this is the mtv music generator for
the first original sony playstation
and this was a game if you can call it
that that you can use to compose music
and people actually use this to compose
music
and this here is the norwegian band
taehyun who had a minor hit on national
radio in norway uh back in the early
noughties with this song called india
pindell
but it's not only tame using their
playstations and taking their
playstations out to perform live on
stage on tour using game equipment to
create music loads of people have used
the game boy and still use the game boy
to create music and the band anak
maguchi
actually created the soundtrack for
scott pilgrim versus the world in 2010
and it reached number three in the
billboard shots with music created on
the game boy also
behind the alias dr spin who had a
big top 10 hit in the uk in 1992 with
the soundtrack for tetris remix in the
dance version hides the famous name
andrew lloyd webber so computer music
has been created by loads of people in
loads of different ways
and
it's still being used and it's good fun
to see people playing a game boy on
stage
16-bit graphic technology and 10-channel
mega stereo sound
the most advanced video game system in
the universe
yes
mega drive from sega the sega mega drive
and why this is important is because of
this little beauty here this is another
yamaha sound chip but compared to the
one in the atari st this one is an
actual legend and you've all heard this
one because this one is the one that is
set inside the yamaha dx7 synthesizer
and that is the synthesizer that aha
play on their blockbuster hit take on me
so suddenly computer game musicians had
this beauty
the
yamaha sound chip that was responsible
for one of the
biggest puppets ever to play around with
boy did they create they created lots of
great music such as this music for
street fighter 2 which is
really a good piece of music to create a
backstory to characters which is not
really easy to do in a fighting game
but street fighter is really really
important in other ways and that is
because it had influenced
other genres of music entirely
[Music]
yes this was a piece of hip-hop this is
another piece of jazz so this is uh
camacho washington jr who loved playing
street fighter when he was a kid
creating his own character soundtrack
for a street fighter
and uh
street fighter had a massive influence
on hip-hop all these artists and in some
way
sampled different parts of street
fighter music for
their songs and there are loads of
famous artists on there but most
important one is maybe lupe fiasco which
is another rapper because lupe fiasco
went up against
the
world champion street fighter player
daigo umejara
in a tournament match
which lupe fiasco ended up winning
and i think that is sort of a
manifestation of how much the game
street fighter has meant to the entire
hip-hop genre
where you have sub-genres such as the
music we heard first which isn't
entirely based around the themes from
the street fighter games
so street fighter
has had such importance for the world
this is the game wing commander
[Music]
and when you have a cinematic intro like
you just saw you sort of such a bar
and wing commander was one of the first
ever games to sort of try to create a
soundtrack that wasn't just music
playing in the background
and what chris roberts designed this
game wanted to create was sort of a
space opera in the style of star wars
and you can if you listen to the music
you sort of hear that influence in there
but what it did was that he created a
music engine for his game where the
music sort of adapts to the action on
screen very subtly but this was a small
start of something big that was about to
come
and this one is a classic game this is
monkey island 2 using the interactive
music streaming engine also known as
imuse
and imuse is the result of composer
michaels lands frustration on working on
the soundtrack for the first monkey
island game
because he really wanted to create
music that sort of accented the gameplay
and he did that here so when you hear or
see guybra streepwood walking around
scab island here you can listen and hear
the music adapt as he moves along and
around the island and this was sort of
one of the first times that music was
really used as a pit orchestra in the
same way a director directs it at the
opera or the theater to
sort of use the music to create even
more action in the game so this was a
good period
this was not a good period this is one
of the original sony playstation adverts
and sony playstation was marketed in
nightclubs to adults and that did
something about the soundtrack it had
sort of the electronic music of the 90s
as a soundtrack loads of great music
but rather bad
game music it was a dark age for the
game music because this is just
background music it's just score in the
background it has nothing to do with the
gameplay what it did have is that it
influenced sort of the sales and saved
some of the bands who had
albums that didn't sell that well
because they could license their music
to games
but it wasn't really all that to get
good game music you need limited
hardware and the nintendo 64 had that
and the legendary soundtrack for the
legendary game gold i-64 soda has that
mashup between john barry's music faith
numbers we care a lot and big booming
drums
now this is on a game console that
didn't even have a sound processor
it had to use the main processor to do
everything it did have a d a converter
that theoretically had
up to 100 sample channels with 28
kilohertz 16 bit sounds only the
cartridges didn't have the possibilities
to store that amount of data so the
composers working on this had to revisit
the techniques being used
in the 1980s and early 1990s by the
computer
musicians that we met earlier to be able
to piece together music in a nice way
and create this little rather beautiful
soundtrack that sets that james bond
atmosphere quite
quite exactly
and
another thing that was done on the
nintendo 64
is
music for this one
where cochicondo introduced
algorithmically generated music into the
mix
so this is a level known as the endless
staircase
and it's a staircase unless you're ready
for it that goes on forever and ever and
ever ever and ever it just goes up and
up but coach humber uses a musical
illusion here known as the shepherd
scale because if you listen to the music
the pitch just keeps going up and up and
up and up and up and forever and ever
keeps on going up and it's an
auditory illusion where two scales are
moving in parallel and it fools your
brain so this is where algorithms came
into play
now this is the iphone app bloom
which was released in 2008 just after
apple opened the app store for the
iphone and this is an app created by the
musician brian eno
now you also see his album ambient one
music for airport from 1978's and this
album was where
the phenomena known as ambient music
started
now brian eno allowed you to create
algorithmically generated music by just
touching the screen here
and it's quite soothing and it has that
soundtrack and brian eno actually also
created the soundtrack for the game
spore
and if you listen
the music here sounds like
the music created by the blue map but it
was this is actually programmed in a
visual programming language called pure
data
which you see here where you have the
possibility to go in and configure
different variables but all of the music
you hear
is all
rhythmically generated and it can adapt
to various variables set by the players
now one thing about these kinds of
soundtracks is that they tend to be like
spa music they tend to be like bad chill
out music they tend to be a bit boring
and that's the thing
that they set out to change with the
game no man's sky
and the music for no man's sky is
created by the math rock band 16 days of
static
now no man's sky is a universe with 18
quintillion planets that you can visit
and you need an ever adapting soundtrack
to adapt to that
endless space
and
being a math rock band 16 days of static
we're used to thinking about algorithms
maths and those kinds of structures we
as programmers think about when they
created this soundtrack
so they have loads of different pieces
of music they can piece together and
sort of create an evocative soundtrack
that fits different planets of this this
universe and adapts
seamlessly
but 18 days of static creating the music
for for this game is the first time that
that proper bands and proper artists
have created video game soundtracks
this is the game quake
and the soundtrack for quake was created
by the industrial rock band nine inch
nails and if you listen to this you hear
that sort of
gritty industrial rock sound of nine
inch nails which fits the gameplay
perfectly and the perfect match for
quake
but one thing is that real big artists
such as david bowie also created
soundtracks for games
so this is a song by the late great day
with bowie from the game omnicron
and this
piece of music is only available in this
cutscene which is deep into the game and
david bowie also lent his voice to the
voiceovers for for this game so there
are some rarities by musicians out there
that you wouldn't have in your record
collection at home
so
one obvious one
is
michael jackson's moonwalker
now this is entirely based around the
music of michael jackson in hindsight
the idea of having michael jackson
walking around buildings picking up
children wasn't probably the best of
ideas but it's definitely smooth
criminal that's playing in the
background
and michael jackson was quite involved
with sega who released and created this
game but one thing that people don't
really
know
is his involvement in sonic the hedgehog
games
so this is the music of sonic 3 sonic
and knuckles
laid on top of michael jackson's song
stranger in moscow
and as you can hear
they fit on top of each other perfect
[Music]
so the rumors about michael jackson
creating the music for sonic the
hedgehog are actually true
sonic the hedgehog came out two years
prior to
michael jackson's song and it's very
unlikely that
it was michael jackson copying sega
there
he created the music but he didn't want
it released because he didn't really
like the low fi
sound even in 10 channel mega stereo
sound on the sega mega drive
this is one of my
all-time favorites and this sound is
really an example of how we also early
video games could have faithful
recreations of soundtracks this is mega
blast by bomb the base which is a sample
based hip hop game and david whittaker
has really gone to lengths to recreate
the sound of that sort of underground
dance hit in the game by the bitmap
brothers
and with that personal favorite we'll go
into the present time
because one of the big album releases
last summer
was a video game soundtrack
this is the video game soundtrack for
the game red dead redemption 2. and
starting with the first red dead
redemption
we saw a change in how music was created
they created tons of tons of tons of
tracks in the same
in the same tempo
all in the key of a minor which is a
really unforgiving key to play in
that the game engine
can mix together
adapting to the gameplay in the manner
that michael land had started
with monkey island
but in an entirely new way with natural
sounding
music played by people but blending
together perfectly mixed by a computer
and soda when while we're at western
music
this hair
is music gen created entirely by the by
a computer using artificial intelligence
this is a piece of western music created
by open ai's musenet and this is a deep
neural network
that can generate four minute musical
competitions using ten different
instruments
and it can combine styles like country
music to
sort of classic
sexy style beatles pop music
it's not programmed to explicitly
understand music but it's programmed to
read music and create something that
sounds like what it's heard before
which brings us to this because this is
the band shige
and it's a project
by flow machines
and it's written by an ai
inspired by french pop music from the
1980s
[Music]
and they also probably got an ai to
write
the lyrics for this one it sounds like
me four years old thinking that i was
speaking english it's all gibberish and
nonsense
but this is an interesting project it's
inspired by tc french pop music from the
1980s
and
there are similar projects to the flow
machines one out there there's something
called jutec and google have their
magenta project
but the reason why people are investing
into machines creating pop music you can
see if you look back to the 2008 monster
hit by travis scott and drake called
sicko mode
if you look at the writing credits on
that one you have 30 people credited on
the writing credits for that song and
one of the reasons for that is that
where the big money and music are these
days is in songwriting and if you can
come up with an ai that writes
compelling puppets you're going to be
a very rich person
[Music]
yes a piece of folk music
and as you might have guessed this is
also ai generated
but in comparison to what we heard
before from the muse ai you know the
country and western music we heard
is that this is actually played by
humans but it's written by a computer
and it's written by a project called
folk rrn it's a recurring
neural network
but what's interesting here is that
this actually works out pretty well it
sounds like
believable folk music and one of the
reasons for this is that in the
tradition of folk musicians musicians
have heard something that someone else
has been playing and played their own
interpretation of that
and in that way music has evolved and
moved from
player to player
and new songs have emerged
and that is the very same way
that ai learns how to create music so ai
writing folk music is just a logical
progression of how folk music has always
been written but it was played by people
and people add a bit of feeling to this
machines are making most of the music
now have you noticed that have you
noticed that all the songs sound the
same
i mean i don't know if you've noticed
that i mean
they mean you could be hearing one song
i mean you could take the lyrics from
another song and put it right on to uh
because the rhythms are the same you
know the drum and the uh the drones are
the same and they uh
uh
the machines can only do so much you
know they can only
you know they can only make it sound
different so many different kinds of
ways so it doesn't sound different it
sounds all the same and uh that's good
for the industry for the industry
because a lot of people are invent these
machines and need you know and sell
these machines plus it's also very good
because uh you can you can you could uh
you could have your own little band like
a one a one man band with these machines
you know what i mean
you can have your own little band with
these machines
and this was bob dylan
being interviewed way back
in 1986
about the current state of music
but it could just as well have been
yesterday
because
computers
are involved in all the music being
created today computers are helping
writing the music we heard today
but luckily being a musician myself
we still need people to
play the music to get that soul and
feeling out of it and personally i hope
it stays that way
but
there are so many things you can do with
music and the tools are ready and even
if you don't know how to create music
there are so many good tools out there
that just about anyone can become a
musician using computers and you
yourself can be part of computer music
history
thank you and have a nice ndc party
wherever it's happening online
whenever i get home i'll have a drink
with you thanks for seeing this talk
this has been high scores a brief
history of computer music
we've been through lots of music so i'll
just leave you with this little text if
there's anything that you would like to
make a little note of
thank you and have a great reminder of
the embassy
hello and welcome to the seven
commandments of the effective legacy
code maintainer my name is drawl helper
before we start a few words about myself
i'm
i'm a consultant and software developer
i've been developing software for more
than a decade
and i specialize in helping teams write
better code
from time to time i get called
to help with project that derailed a bit
and hello be maintained
or developed
usually i teach test driven development
unit testing clean code and other
practices that help developers
do better job
i'm also a pluralsight auto i have
several courses on pluralsight
two of which on unit testing in c plus
plus and one on aws lambda i have a blog
at helpercode.com
and twitter handle at the helper where
you can reach me
uh i want to talk about why we hate
legacy code
and we do hate legacy code
and there are several reasons everybody
got this
bad feeling in the pit of their stomach
when they need to write new
functionality or even maintain legacy
code and not for be without any reason
basically
red legacy because because it was
written
in the past a while ago usually using
obsolete technologies tools and
practices
and it's a pain to maintain it nobody
wants to use
all the things from the past all of us
want to work with the latest and
greatest and on top of that working with
those
old technologies means that usually
it's a pain to change things
and we need to follow certain practices
or even write code that we don't really
like
now
also with legacy code it's very easy to
break stuff
whatever we change
we have the feeling that we might break
some existing functionality
and
that causes us to change less
we even get to a point with some code
bases in which we have no clue what
might break in any change we make
and so
it's very hard to walk this way it's
like stepping through a minefield yeah
in any moment
you might break something or something
will stop walking
and then you will try to understand what
the
what happened and how to fix it and it's
not a good place to be
and thus nobody knows how that legacy
code works
it was written a while ago and people
have no clue
no one knows what certain functionality
how it will behave when you try to
change it
or
or tweak it or how it affects other
parts of the system
some of time you don't even show what
the requirement was when that code was
written all those things
basically cause us a lot of pain when
maintaining legacy code and no one
really liked to do that
now
when you start to work with legacy code
there are certain
guidelines or rules that i found to be
helpful
in order to reduce the amount of pain or
completely eliminated and the first
thing is
do no harm do no harm first do no harm
was coined by a non-legacy code
maintainer from ancient greece called
hippocrates
he said we practice two things when
dealing with diseases either help or do
not harm the patient
something
some people think that's part of their
book a hippocratic oath
not sure about that at least i couldn't
find it but i did find it in epidemics
book one and maintaining the human body
and legacy code is very similar someone
else created it
and now we have a problem and we want to
make sure that we don't break anything
when we try to solve that problem
basically
and that's for good reason because
legacy code has two things going for it
first
if you change something and break it
you'll probably be left over the weekend
trying to fix whatever you broke or
until the middle of the night and all of
us like to go back home at some point
all of us have hobbies and families
that we want to meet from time to time
so we try not to change or at least not
break anything with legacy code but the
real reason we don't want to break
anything
is because of one single truth
it has users
those users really care about your code
working they use it
probably
daily or at least at some point to do
their job
and they wanted to continue work in in
exactly the same way
those users are the only reason you're
maintaining this piece of code
because if there weren't no user if this
particular part of the system
wouldn't generate any revenues or
wouldn't be beneficial to anyone
you probably wouldn't be trying to fix
it or add new features so those users
are someone you care about this piece of
code is very important to someone so you
don't want to break it so you want to
make sure that you keep everything
working the same way
or at least the functionality that
is still there
keep walking the same way without
breaking it that's not an easy task to
do
what usually happens
when developers need to maintain such
code and are afraid to change anything
they try to make small changes not
change too much don't rock the ship
and you don't
want to do that either you write very
small changes or you write ad hoc
changes you debug the code get to a
certain point you see that it might
solve your problem you write as little
code as you can and then you close that
file and run away
but unfortunately that practice
at least in my experience will cause the
code shares to be less maintainable
the next change will be even harder
and after a week a month a year it will
be impossible to change anything in your
code so we don't want to do that
in the good book
working effectively with legacy code
written by michael fedors which you
should read still relevant
he said that we need to mitigate the
risk and we have to ask three questions
now answering those three questions is
not simple but they should
be in the back of our head when we
maintain legacy code
those questions are what changes do we
have to make and it's not just what code
to write is
it's about the existing functionality
and how we want to transform it to the
new functionality what does that involve
which objects classes functions
values are affected but what by whatever
change we make
and we need to map those
second we need to answer
how do we know that we finish working
and we fix the bug or add a new
functionality how do we know that we
made the changes and they are working do
we debug the code
do we run a test with if we have one
uh do we give some
tester or product manager the ability to
check our work we need to define those
and finally
how do we know that we haven't broken
anything and unless we can answer those
three questions
it's impossible to change code with
confidence
now there's more to it than that that
just uh outlining
what we need to do
but there are quite a few things we need
to do in order to be able to answer
those questions the first one
is we need to make sure
that this piece of code
runs
on our machine or at least in some
controlled environment
because
i've been to a projects in which only
one machine could debug
and deploy
creating installer
for a specific piece of code
only jim's machine can run that piece of
code that's a problem you don't want
that you want that code to run on any
machine
even if it means somehow creating a
virtual machine out of g machines so we
can run it in every developer machine
or at least understand the problems that
cause it not to run on my machine is it
an environment that i'm missing some
third-party library i need to install
maybe configuration
something here i need to configure and
fix in order to run it on my machine and
i need to be able to do the following
three otherwise there's no point in
continuing
now we don't live in the perfect world
and i've been in projects in which
people couldn't compile their code but
it's almost impossible to change code
you can't compile
it sounds
crazy but i've been today
i've been working with legacy systems
for a while now and i've seen pieces of
code that developers don't even compile
because they need a special tool and
that will only run on the build server
and that server it will take it between
15 and 20 minutes to run that's a
problem that's something we need to
think about how to change because i want
to be able to compile the code i need to
be able to run the code on my machine
and i need to understand what it means
and hopefully i'll manage to do that
and finally
deploy
i need to know what it means to take
this code i just wrote and give it to my
customers or pass it along to the next
point of the pipeline to testers
or staging environment
whatever it means in this specific
project and the reason i want to do
those
is in order to be able
to debug the code without debugging the
code it's almost impossible to know what
works and what doesn't work
and without debugging the code
and
it will be impossible to test it even
manually if i can't run the code i can
test it obviously and the tools i'm
using won't be able to help me refactor
the code so i won't be able to improve
it
and i probably wouldn't be able to run
most analyze analysis tools
which i do want to most of them will
help me do a better job
and without all those it's impossible to
move the code forward without all those
only i'm left out with
is change whatever i think is working
send it over and hope no one will find a
bug and call me in the middle of the
night
or the customer accidentally get
a bug in his production system
so i have to make sure i can run the
code once i have it running then i ready
to go to the next step
which is understand the code before you
change it
also sounds very trivial but i can't
count the times in which i saw people
uh going and changing stuff and
adding features
and moving code around
without actually knowing what goes there
and you need to be able to understand
what the code does
and it's not easy
it's not simple understanding
what a specific piece of code does
because it's legacy code means that even
if you have any documentation
it will probably be obsolete by this
time because things have changed
and maybe it was true when the project
began or when
we finished shipping the first version
but then things changed bugs were found
new features wired integration team came
in and changed a few things
so the documentation in most
cases does not hurt me at all
the second thing is that
i don't really know who to ask
the people who wrote the code
probably is not around anymore some of
them move to other projects some of them
left the company
it's very hard to find someone
with an old enough code base to
understand exactly what happens there
and if you do find this person
keep him you'll have someone to ask
but most of the time even if you find
the person who wrote the code it doesn't
remember and if it does remember
uh things have changed since he wrote
the code other people went in added new
code move things around fix a bug maybe
did a few stuff
a few changes along the way
and he will look at the code and say i
don't remember doing that
and it might be his memory
and it might be the fact that thing
changed afterwards
the third thing is that that code grew
over time
things were added along the way
small methods become
huge methods
more parameters world shoved in new
functionality was added
and
things have grown since
the that project was shipped or
since we start working on it
and finally probably by different people
so there's no one person to ask so what
can you do
if you want to understand a piece of
code it was just given and i've been in
this situation
i've came to companies and they gave me
a huge method or a piece of
functionality they told me
roughly what they think it does
said well let's see if we can improve it
and
then what you do well first of all
ask around
start asking people maybe you'll end up
finding someone who knows everything at
least about what that code supposed to
do
in some companies there's
this guy or girl that knows everything
does know about that project and if
you'll find him or her
then you're lucky you just save yourself
a lot of time
you do want to read the documentation as
obsolete as it is at least you get the
original intent you know what the code
was supposed to do
don't spend a lot of time on it but at
least find whatever you can
maybe someone drew a diagram maybe
someone wrote the requirements
just check it out it might help you
another thing that helps me a lot is
refactoring when i go into a huge method
or a method that i can't understand i
start playing around i'm doing a small
refactoring that i can safely do in
existing code when i pair program with
another developer i usually tell him we
are going to change the code a bit don't
worry about it if you don't like the end
result
we'll revert everything we'll undo all
the changes but first i need to
understand what goes there
i'm not trying to improve the code at
this point just to understand it
i'll follow a bunch of code into a
method try to give it a good name
i'll change variable names ask someone
what this variable does or go back and
find out what was the
idea behind this variable change its
name so i'll be able to understand the
code better
now remember i told you you have to be
able to read the code
that's because at this point i want to
debug it
i want to run the code on my machine
hopefully
if not on some remote machine
and go line by line and understand what
values goes in what values goes out
as the product manager as someone who
knows
the client how that code that product is
being used and go through it and see how
it affects
the parts that you care about
go line by line document it write it
down
because the next step will be try to
draw a diagram
or a code map
that shows you
the flow
the important stuff doesn't need to be a
formally a male diagram
just a bunch of squares with arrows
between them will be enough at this
point
in fact i've did i've done this several
times and at least two times
the customer was so happy with the end
result in the first one it became part
of the project documentation
because no one documented the core
functionality of the application and
once i did they were able to take it on
to other teams
the other time i wrote a nice diagram
showing which method calls which method
in which class and
roughly the idea of what that meant does
went through it with the customer it was
three pages long my drawing i did it
with a powerpoint or something like that
uh visio
and then the client went with me and
said well i can see that step 3 7 and 15
does exactly the same thing we can
probably eliminate them
and step four will never happen
and you gain a lot of insights about
what the code does which will help you
not break it because you need to
understand
uh what exactly the code does in order
to keep it working the same way
now there are several tools that will
help you along the way
and one of them which i use always when
dealing with net
code is and depend
and depend dependency graph
will if you can compile the code on your
machine you can create a bunch of
matrixes and uh dependency graph is just
the beginning and you can immediately
see
how the different objects relate to one
another and you can find a bunch of
problems and ideas in job between data
and the code easily it's very fluent
it's very easy to use
in the end of this talk i'll give you a
coupon code if you like to purchase it
but you can try it out for 30 days
decide for yourself that's a very nice
tool to use another one
is a resharper which has an architecture
graph not sure if all the shopper users
know that
and same for intellij and other tools it
will draw the relation between the
assemblies so at least you know which
uses what and you can focus on the ones
that you care about as you see what i
did
so i'll be able to understand that if i
make a change in services it affects
web framework and
exchange and whatever in a project i
never saw before
and all those things will help me gain
understanding
now
the other thing i said is that i use
refractor in order to gain the ability
because the number one offender with
legacy code
my experience is huge methods methods
that stretch as far as the eye can see
those are impossible to read and
impossible to understand and you don't
need to really work out together just
make sure that you only make small
changes all the time and you end up with
the huge methods which usually happen
with such code
and
the easy part is just look for if
statements or comments in the code and
just mark a bunch of code and use your
id of choice in order to extract that to
a new method
and all modern ideas will give you that
functionality in most old ideas as well
xlibs intellij visual studio code
uh visual studio widow without resharper
will extract blocks into methods give
them good names and you'll be able to
see the functionality and
don't try to fix everything at this
point even if you see duplicate code if
you think if you think there's a better
way to write this code at this point you
don't want to break anything so don't do
make any new changes
just four things inside methods and
you'll be able to see the flow
for example
this is the
gilded rose refactor in qatar by emily
bach
and this is the main method and as you
can see it's not unreadable but it's
hard to understand how the different
four if if if else and so on relate to
one another
this is also known as the arrow
arrowhead pattern because it looks like
this when you have a lot of it's nested
if statements
and you can really fix this code easily
using your
favorite id
because
all you have to do is mark a bunch of if
statements and follow them inside the
method and in looking on this code
roughly we can see that we're using a
forced
for loop but in fact we always take in
the same item the item in this index we
can change it to for each also the first
line
um
up here we can tell that it's asking if
something is not this and not this and
not that so probably i can inverse the
if statement not understand what exactly
is done here and same goes for here and
i can see blocks there's
one block here another block in the else
statement that i can probably break into
this part and whatever goes below that
method stretches quite a long
time you need a very big screen to see
it if you can manage or you can just
extract things into methods and it will
look like this and now i can understand
what it does
if the name is not whatever bree or
backstage passes then decrease item
quality
else handle special items whatever that
means
if the item name is not supports end of
ragnaros then you need to reduce the
selling price
and if it's below zero item expiry data
just passed
now we can see the flow
now some people don't
care for this kind of a factor and they
say okay now i need to
dig in and dig out of the method to
understand what it does
well first of all that's a central
factor digest for readability you don't
like it develop
and do
but
in
fact this is uh basically a way to see
the actual code flow
people tend to say something i don't
really understand about the code telling
a story
but if you want to use this specific
allegory
if the code tells a story it needs to be
precise
if you go to your friend on monday
morning ask him what did you do in the
weekend
you don't want to hear i woke up at 10
30 and then i went to brush my teeth i
sat on the couch for 15 minutes
and then
i ate breakfast went all the way to the
door opened the door went out locked the
door went all the way to makal started
my car and so on and so on obviously
this is
too much information
you want to be able
to ask him what did he do in the weekend
and he will say i've been to the beach
and then you can ask him oh that's nice
what did he do at the beach when did you
arrive at the beach that's like going
inside a method
and he will say i arrived at 10 30
because i woke up late or i like to
sleep late and we can have a
conversation that both of us understand
no one falls asleep in the middle of it
same for your code
every method should be one layer you
don't want to
over expose everything and once you fall
things inside method easily this way
and you can do it with your refactoring
tool of choice
you don't break anything or in some
languages you might but
in most you don't and all tools know how
to
properly factor into a method
and you'll be able to understand what it
does now we can understand this code and
we can change it and we need to change
it doesn't work
in
no way that i want it to work and
there's a lot of duplication but at
least now i can see parts in boxes that
are easily to understand
so once i understand the code what do i
know what do i need to do well now i
need to change it to finally got to the
important part
we need to change it with confidence
we need to be able to know that we
haven't broken anything and that we
managed to implement whatever they ask
us to do
and for that you need automatic test
there's no two ways about it
it is impossible to make sure that you
haven't broken anything unless you have
tests that run
continuously either on all commits or at
least once a day
and make sure that whatever
they are testing is still working
on top of that tests give you a quick
feedback you finish
implementing something fixing a bug you
run all the tests you see that you
haven't broken anything at least to the
best of your knowledge
you should get a bug at motes
but at least you're in a better place
than having no tests at all
also once you have tests in place
then the next time you'll need to change
something you don't need to run the
whole application have any projects in
which running application can take
between 10 to
35 minutes
i don't want to write to run that
application every time make a change i
want to run just a test and debug it and
see that everything is fine
so i want automatic test in place but
unfortunately it's not always easy
because we are talking about legacy code
obsolete tools obsolete
methodologies probably to begin with
without a lot of tests on it
and then we have a dilemma
the legacy code dilemma as it was
called in the working effectively with
legacy code book
in order to change the code we need to
add tests in order to change the code
without breaking anything we need test
unit tests integration test component as
whatever
but for adding tests usually to begin
with we need to change the code
now we can
go in circles
all the time
or
because we can't do anything and we
stuck essentially in this point
now one
thing we can do
is write integration tests in our tests
and to enter whatever scope we can
in order to make sure that at least some
of the functionality behaves properly
that might take a while
and those tests does they won't be they
might be fragile at this point but i
want them to run
to the in the duration of the time it
takes me to get to write in unitas so
i'll write those tests as end-to-end
integration tests whatever whatever
scope i can usually it's easier because
taking a huge pile of code testing it
from end to end is easier than trying to
understand the different parts
inside the code in order to write unit
tests and you gain some insight by
writing tests even end-to-end tests and
then you refactor your code so you can
write unit tests
and then you get to decide if you want
to delete those integration tests or
keep them in place depending on how
fragile they are if they break all the
time for them away if not that's a good
thing to have
and writing unit tests is possible
another thing i can do is what i'm
called
safely factoring
safely factoring is basically
a bunch of small things i can do that
doesn't break the code extract into a
method renaming stuff
um
adding things that doesn't change the
existing functionality we'll get to that
extracting an interface from a class all
those things won't change what the code
does but it will help you write unit
test because the difference between
end-to-end or integration tests and unit
tests is that
you have dependencies in your code that
you don't want to run
when you run unit as you want to run
in an isolated fashion
divided
in
from your actual services or file or
database because those things
will cause a
noise
yeah you don't want your test to fail
because the service is not running you
don't want it to fail because the
database doesn't have permissions all
the correct values there but in order to
change those you first need to
understand them which hopefully you know
by now because you
read the code debugged it
and added some end-to-end tests
and now you want to replace all of those
dependencies with fake objects
or mock objects depending on how you
like to call those
and once you do have those fake objects
which are usually done
easily by in using a mocking framework
that inherit the original object
and override all of the methods so they
do absolutely nothing
and
unless i tell them to do something else
in the tests now if you never walked a
good fake object with mock objects i
suggest you
find some good tutorials online or
in your unit testing framework or your
in a
code uh
programming language of choice
uh you need those you can't do without
but once i have those fake objects i
need to be able to go in
and pull the little object out
and put in the fake object
and in order to do that
i need
to open
parts of my code
so i'll be able to do that
um
in some frameworks is easier and some
frameworks are there but basically it is
known as dependency injection now a lot
of modern programming use depends
injection but unfortunately not
everybody works on modern code bases
so we need to find a way to do depends
injection when it was not written there
to begin with
and then
you need to
do something
usually it means either extracting
interfaces for existing class because
people used to program against base
classes in the past
and not pass them through the
constructor
you can create another constructor this
is the number one way to create
dependency injection you have a
construct that does absolutely without
any parameters and inside a bunch of
initialization create another
constructor that all of the objects on
the outside just use it in your tests
that will be good enough to begin with
if you have absolutely no choice
you can create accessors and delegators
those are special methods that you use
for tests
and unfortunately
[Music]
those things
will cause the code to look
not as neat and people will accidentally
use them in production
you don't want that but if you have no
choice at this point
do whatever it takes
you can even pass functionalities
delegates uh methods lenders whatever
in order to encapsulate it and change it
in your code
now remember that when working with
legacy codes it's very similar
to roadside construction
if you trying to take a roundabout and
replace it with a different kind of
intersection
in the beginning
there will be holes in the road in the
beginning there will be traffic jams and
people will be late to walk
but
slowly but surely things will get fixed
and will change to the way you want so
don't worry if you do a lot of
small
things that will help you better test
the code because they will go away
after a while
but in the beginning you need to open
those bunch of holes in your code in
order to replace dependencies
one of those patterns there are quite a
lot of patterns is called extract and
override this is a pattern i only use if
i have absolutely no other choice
usually when someone did something bad
in the constructor
um
most of the time it has to do something
to do with the database
exact on over that says i'm running the
code it crashes it crashes because of
some dependencies was initialized
when
and i can't
change it with depends injection what
i'll do
i'll take that piece of code i'll
extract it to a method a virtual
protected method
i create a subclass in my test
that inherits that class that has this
piece of code in and overwrite them
offending method
and then i can test it
i'll show you what i mean
here we have um
the trip service cutter the chip service
cutter basically is another nice code in
cutter that has to do with legacy code
and as we can see i have a user session
here
this is a class it's a singleton we can
tell by the private constructor
and by
the static method called get instance
it's a bit of a naive implementation
and it has two methods
and both of them will follow an
exception that it's intended to show us
that the database is not there so we're
not allowed to call those methods in our
unit tests but we want to test
another method that uses this singleton
and unfortunately it was used in a very
naive way i have a method i want to test
called get rips by user
and it uses that user service here
now i have several things i can do with
this singleton class
the first of which
i can go inside that class pack
uh change the constructor to protect it
and add another
[Music]
protected
set instance
that receive a user
session
and
set the user session
equal
new instance
and that
and obviously need to be static method
now
we're done
now obviously on top of the compilation
problem there are ways to do that but
they are not nice
i just spoke in the singleton and
someone might use that against me
another
more elegant solution
is
is to take this class because on top of
the singleton part there are actual here
and do a quick refactoring
and those are a bunch of refactoring to
do with the shopper but all of them are
possible with visual studio and of
course
yeah and i saw them in eclipse and
intellij
will work quite a lot and you can
extract a new interface
now i'll extract a new user session
and implement and
define those two methods i need and now
i have an interface that i can easily
fix because it has nothing to do with
the singleton
and then i'll go back to the code
this piece of code and i can add
i use a
session like so
and use that
and the signal term call will go to
whoever calls this method
now i can fake that easily in my tests
and now i can test this piece of code
now
it's a good thing to push all your
singletons as
high as you can the beginning of whoever
initialized all the system
uh you can't always do that but what i
did basically means that whoever uses
the singleton in other places in the
code will continue functioning the same
way just this method was changed now i
need to fix only this method which
basically is finding all the places in
which that method was called
and just pass the right parameters now
it could be a few dozen places now in
this case there's another solution
that's extract and override which i told
you
is the last result
a result
so basically what extract and override
means is i'll take this line
like so
and use another extract method
yes
and i've got a
get
logged user
and going back
it's not static
it's i'll turn it into protected
virtual
get logged user now in my tests
i'll
override
this class
the one i'm uh
trying to test i'll
inherit it in gear trips by using a trip
service for tests
and in trip service for tests i will
override that method that causes me a
bit of grief
and whatever is returned from my user
session
then i'll return my own user depending
on what i need to do in this specific
test so this is basically extract
and override
simple as that
now obviously the class is not better
for it but as i said this is something
we do in order to test it right now
and hopefully
when we do a bunch of those things we'll
change the code quite a bit and in the
end we'll end up with
something that we can either move to
another dependency injection framework
ioc container or we can find other ways
to do that but at this point i can at
least test the functionality in this
class until i get at least to this which
is static methods
but i can do the same tricks i just
showed you with the static method as
well
now that's not the only pattern as i
said
you can add depends injection
constructed injection method injection
like i showed you even put a setup
property
all of those are valid
and you need to be pragmatic about it do
whatever works for you
find ways to test your code
then find ways to make it better not the
other way around because then
you'll make sure that your code doesn't
break
now the fifth commandment
is clean up before you leave
well
yeah
it was coined by another by uncle bob
robert martin in the book clean code
another good book to read it's not big
and it says always leave the code you
read it in a little better than you
found it also known as the boy scout
wall because boy scouts leave the
campsite
cleaner than they found it
don't be that guy that says
it was like this when i got here
i had a friend a very talented developer
and
i did a code review
and i asked him why didn't you write any
unit as he said because that class
didn't have any units to begin with
that's not a good excuse
you always want to improve it
and improving the code is not hard
do things that makes you feel better
if it hurts change it this piece of code
has hurt us in the past it's unreadable
maybe it has some bugs in
and in one team we had the rule of three
if a specific piece of code annoys us
three times or more we will find ways to
improve it and change it
some changes are easier than others
again
using safely factoring once you have
unitas you can do bigger and better
kind of changes
you can easily make the code look better
and you can do that
even by a simple rename just renaming a
variable to says say whatever it does
another thing you want to do delete that
code you know those commented that
pieces of code remove them
it's a mental load to read through those
pieces of code all the time i hate that
just delete those codes it won't benefit
you in any way whatsoever at this point
because they are not even being compiled
and you need to delete
that code all the time because you have
source control that keeps your code
forever and you don't need to
keep it
in your code it has absolutely no
purpose and in one or two or three
months time it will be irrelevant in
either way
you really want to keep it
just save it in a document and put it
somewhere don't keep your mess in the
code
and the changes are tremendous those
small changes rename and delete that
code will improve your code doesn't
matter what you do
here another example from the
refactoring cutter
written by the late scotland
and a very good
quadcopter
to perform
i usually do that when talking about
refactoring because to begin with that
code is unreadable you have no idea what
this method does take a while look at it
there's a fine method returns f yet an
ft
and then it runs on p
and with new f it has birthday there's a
name there
and a bunch of things but and when
walking through this code you understand
a bunch of things about all those
names and you can rename them just use
rename in your
uh ide in this case visual studio you
end up with something much better like
this this is the same piece of code i
haven't changed anything and i can
extract methods and do other things here
but for now
it's easy to understand i'm running on
persons they have a birth date
and i'm trying to see the age difference
between those persons in order to get
the best pair whatever that means
and the code suddenly is readable all i
did is file for renaming i renamed the
name for person query to query by
it was f
for pale
and
ft for query by
and p for person and everything is
slightly better
it can be further improved and should be
further improved but at least it's not
as painful reading it all the time even
if you have
an idea what those names means before
you always need to think a minute
to think
you have like this hash table in here it
says okay ft
is the query
and
f is a pair of two persons
and p is a person and that's
a fracture of a second or 10 seconds it
takes you to remember that
it's painful but the fun thing fact is
that it's you only notice it was painful
when it stopped being painful after you
do a rename
always clean your code don't overdo it
but
make sure that you leave the code in a
better shape than you found it
now doing all that things is a bit time
consuming but you have to remember
something when working with the with
legacy code because the legacy code
can
take quite a while to fix properly or
so-called properly
forget your don't forget you're on the
clock
maybe the first day no one will bother
you but after day or two your manager
will come and ask you what are you
working on and why you are not done yet
you need to remember that everything
takes time you need to estimate what can
you do in a day a week a month and how
much time people will give you to do it
for example
in a project i worked
for a while ago
we had
the code of the core business of our
company it was called the switch process
and that's which process was written
over time
and it had a bunch of boolean values and
bunch of events and it was very hard to
see the flow it was really hard to
understand what happens there and after
half a year of working on it we
understood that there are better
patterns that will make the code better
and easy to understand debug and make
sure no bugs are hidden there
because that was crucial to the company
and my friend got the job of refactoring
that code
but before that my manager asked him how
much time will it take he said well two
weeks
the manager thought about it for one
said well right now we don't have two
weeks
um we'll do that next time when we have
two weeks
i'll tell you a secret we never did it
we never did it because you'll never
have enough time you have to estimate
not how much it will take but how much
will be given for you to do it
and if it takes two weeks don't say two
weeks
just tell your manager well
after they will be there after two days
will be there after a week will be
all the way over here because you have
to break things to smaller tasks and
make sure that he knows what he commits
for
and each such task will
move you closer and closer to whatever
you're trying to achieve and every one
of them will improve whatever you're
working on
and you'll end up with doing the two
weeks you wanted
but one day at a time so always remember
things take time and usually we don't
have that time
so do small changes
on top of small changes
try not to break the system for long
periods of time in the beginning when i
worked on legacy code
i used to find good ideas and i wanted
to change this pattern and change the
way the code walk and i will change
about three things and the card would
stop compiling and after the two days
three days i'll get it to compile again
and debug it run a test
and find out that i made a mistake it's
not the right thing i was supposed to do
so i'll revet everything and go back and
that's not a good idea
you want to keep those cycle as small as
possible
you want to break
everything you do into small tasks
in the end of each task you want to
commit
yeah to commit your code if you're
working with a source control
such as git you can locally commit just
so that if you find a mistake you can
revert to the last save point you have
and once you do that
remember to merge when possible don't
wait too long
whenever all the test passes nothing
broke
and you improve something either you
wrote new functionality or something was
improved you don't have to finish the
task
push it merge it back
and so the code other people called
won't progress without you
you otherwise you'll hand up with a lot
of
merge
fixes and
and the code moved around and now you
have a problem
and also it shows progress
and enable you to find problems sooner
so you have to make sure that the system
keep on working and as soon as possible
merge back if you work with feature
branches
then finish the feature but keep on
merging from the main branch all the
time to make sure that your code is
in sync with whatever goes there
and the last thing you need to do is to
learn and improve
learning proof is a big part of
maintaining legacy code
in the beginning we know absolutely
nothing and as the time go by we learn
quite a lot
and
we can find things that waste most of
our time
and then we find stuff that we can
improve how long does the compilation
take is it too long well let's reduce it
let's split things into different module
assemblies whatever it called in a
language programming language of choice
how much time it takes to run the test
too long okay let's think how to do that
maybe we need to run them only at night
we need to split them to fastest and
slow test
do i wait for the application to start a
few times a day
let's make sure i don't
either by making the startup time less
and less or by running only parts of the
application in the in a test harness or
in some other way
find a way
to make everything take less time
and you'll find places to improve
you can add automation a build server
maybe deployment is done manually it
takes three days reduce it to one day by
using automation reduce it to one hour
maybe
find new tools to help you do your job
better
nothing fun in using new tools either to
analyze the code for you or run it
better and
upgrade libraries when you can
if there's no point in using an old.net
version maybe move to the new one you'll
get new language construct and enable
you
that enable you to prog
to express what you want to do
in some projects you're not allowed to
but in most small upgrades are possible
and slowly but surely improve everything
and connect
measurement tools and metric tools and
analysis tools to your build system and
use them on your machine
again and depend sauna cube
all of those can be added either by you
or if you have a devops team they love
when you give them nice ideas that will
make them and you look better it will
show progress and then the rest of the
team will will notice maybe the rest of
the company will notice and that's a big
important thing about learning and
improving because you need to teach
others you want other people to help you
maintaining the code
and improve
you need to
have the read your code once they read
your code
they understand your code see what
you've done and they'll do the same
thing how do you get people to read your
code
they're obviously not in a reading
session
either pair a program with someone or
better yet ask someone to code review
you
when you get caught review from someone
you learn a lot from him but he learns
quite a lot from you you'll you'll i've
learned how to do new stuff and tests in
different ways by doing code reviews to
other talented developers
get people to review a code they'll see
something they like they'll use it in
their code because basically you're
probably not working alone
on that piece of legacy code what other
people
to follow the same practices that you
found to be effective
and become a knowledge base for your
company
if you're the only one that know how to
maintain that code it's not good
teach others
and people will come to ask you
questions and you gain
some status maybe you'll be promoted at
some point
and the more you know
the more you'll become that person who
knows something about this
and you'll gain insight into your
company business because again you're
working in code
that your company that is crucial to
your company in some way it has
customers maybe or in the internal
external customers you understand what
your company does better than just
writing code
that code is the some knowledge of
everyone who worked on it
to solve some problems from someone else
which is probably how your company is
making money
so you become someone who actually
understand more than just the code you
understand the company if you want to
become a product owner product manager
manager perhaps that's a good way to go
and you will learn practices that will
help you in the next project it will
make it awesome you'll see what happened
what worked what didn't work what you
should or shouldn't do and in the next
project you probably don't make the same
mistakes
and you'll probably be able to improve
and one company i worked for it was a
huge company every developer went
through development
then deployment of the project and
supporting the customer and after a year
or two went back to write the next
latest and greatest project because that
was a good way to teach those developers
what the customers actually need
and how to write purple code and what
not to do the mistakes that
was done in the past we don't need to
repeat them we need to find new mistakes
to do
and
you can harness your team to the effort
because people will see you doing things
that work
they will want to do the same thing they
will help you
in doing the same thing teaching unit
testing without writing with someone
unit test is out but once people see it
working for someone they will try it as
well
same for code they see you doing stuff
that was impossible in the past
and they'll want to do it as well
and then you get the ultimate prize for
being successful in maintaining legacy
code you'll get to do it once again
you get to do it once again because the
reward for doing a good job
is getting more work to do
that's a good thing because all of us
like to write code
and also you'll notice something after a
few weeks a few months
you'll get to make bigger and bigger
changes first of all you have more
confidence in code but more importantly
your manager your team will have more
confidence in you
you are just successful doing something
so you get to do bigger and bigger
things you get more interesting more
important things to do
as the time progress
when i was a new developer in a team and
i wanted to change it
one of the cultural tools there manager
told me that's what happened after
half a year
it was more open to the idea because i
showed him i know what i'm doing i was
successful i had those small wins that
go and go and go until i could change
something very crucial to the system and
improve it because my manager
trusted me
so not only you get to do it again
you get to do it bigger and better
and that's
the end of it then you do it again and
again and again
until at some point you'll probably be
moved to another project or maybe
another position
hopefully not leave the company but
that's up to you
maybe become a consultant and teach
about legacy code
because you'll gain a lot of insight by
doing that because legacy code doesn't
need to be painful
it doesn't be something that people
don't are afraid of
if you do those practices
you'll manage to gain control over your
code
and improve it to a point in which it is
no longer legacy code something that is
maintained
and grown over time
so
to summarize we talked about seven
commandments effective legacy code
nintendo the first of which do no harm
you are not allowed to break anything
then make it work run on your machine
otherwise don't continue
then understand before you change you
need to read the code know what it does
in order that you can maintain that
behavior
and know what you need to change
with confidence confidence equal
automated tests degradation tests and
now you test unit tests especially unit
tests
and then clean up before you leave and
improve the coding event further
remember that you're on the clock
and learn and improve
thank you for listening
to my talk
if you have any questions i can take a
few questions now we have a few minutes
you can
write them down or even ask them
and if not i'll try to be available in
slack and you can always ping me in
twitter
well thank you for listening
you